Ich erinnere mich an Twitch-Chat, von den Tagen, die weg sind.
Twitch-Emojis, vor langer Zeit.
Major Fear.
Ich erinnere mich an Twitch-Chat, von den Tagen, die weg sind.
Twitch-Emojis, vor langer Zeit.
Major Fear.
You're not alone.
Kappa-PogChamp.
Keep a forehead.
BibleThumb.
Twitch-Emojis.
I remember.
Typing-Dance-Games.
Forehead-Swift-Rage.
PJ-Salt-and-Fail-Fish.
Life was easy.
Spamming all the time.
T.O.S. was nowhere.
So everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch-Emojis.
From long ago.
Major Fear.
You're not alone.
Kappa-PogChamp.
Keep a forehead.
BibleThumb.
Twitch-Emojis.
Still here is Bark.
In the morning hour he calls me.
This doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I
missed emotes from yesterday.
Yesterday.
Twitch-Emojis.
From long ago.
Major Fear.
You're not alone.
Kappa-PogChamp.
BibleThumb.
Twitch-Emojis.
Purple Hands.
BibleThumb.
Twitch-Emojis.
Kappa-PogChamp.
From long ago.
Twitch-Emojis.
Sagt mir gar nichts. Was ist das?
Sagt mir überhaupt nichts.
Was, was? Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Backup-Tool, Windows.
Okay, ja. Jedes Backup ist besser als kein Backup.
Big Brain-Weisheit.
Egal, mit welcher Software.
Ein Backup größer, kein Backup.
Ja, also, vollkommen egal, was ich von der Software halte.
Ich mag ja so Windows-Klicke-Software generell nicht.
Aber, alle mal besser als gar keins.
Gestern gefeiert? Nee, ich bin gerade aufgestanden.
Ach, was trinke.
Ahem, so.
Speed-Comparison 2, faster than light.
Ah, so. Okay, ne.
Excellent.
Wie laut ist das Ganze?
Übelst leise.
Da kommt ja gar kein Sound an.
Oh Gott, Kingdom Hearts-Musik, wo kein... Also, die Musik ist nice, aber wie gesagt, das Game, ich weiß nicht.
Mein Fall ist Kingdom Hearts nicht gewesen.
Das Erste, das Erste vielleicht nur halbwegs, ne.
Zwar nicht ganz so, ja.
Ahem.
Okay.
Das Erste vielleicht nur halbwegs, ne. Zwar nicht ganz so, ja.
Was hast du dir angeguckt?
Baustellen-Video? Welches denn?
Das mit den Bildern auf dem Dach?
Das da?
Haha, ich dachte...
Können wir uns zusammen mal den Corona-App-Talk anhören? Ja, schickt mal einen Link.
Du meinst, du meinst nicht das hier, ne. Du meinst, du meinst das andere Video, also das...
Wo ist es denn hin?
Dach.
Hier, das da.
Age-Confirmation, lol.
In dem Video ist überhaupt nichts.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch jetzt mal den krassesten Big-Brain-Twitter, äh, ähm...
Wo kann die Musik mal weitergehen?
Den krassen Big-Brain-YouTube-Pack aller Zeiten.
Oh, und schon ist die Alters-Verification weg.
Das ist was, ha?
Das Video hast du dir angeguckt, ja.
Ja, so sah es bei uns auf der Baustelle aus, hier im Haus.
Da war noch, da war noch der, da war noch der Fahrstuhl da.
Da war noch der Fahrstuhl. Der Fahrstuhl ist nicht mehr da.
Das Ding konntest du nicht ordentlich isolieren.
Da ist jetzt eine Treppe.
Ja, der Fahrstuhl war schon cooler als die Treppe, muss man sagen.
Woher früher sein Atelier hat, der hat Bilder gemalt.
Und man sieht ja schon eine ganz abenteuerliche Konstruktion.
Nämlich einen Fahrstuhl, den er selbst gebaut hat vor 50 Jahren oder so.
Also ganz, ganz abenteuerlich dieses Teil hier.
Guck dir das mal an.
Ja, Umut, können wir uns gleich angucken?
Wobei, das ist ja schon alt, oder? Sehe ich das jetzt falsch?
Oder ist das neu? 16, ne, das ist halbwegs neu.
Können wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Das war aber auch, das war aber auch ein abenteuerliches Teil, ey.
Das war aber auch echt ein abenteuerliches Teil.
Guck mal, das war auch echt ein abenteuerliches Ding.
Man hängt komplett, man hängt komplett an diesem einen Finger liegt, ja.
Ja, so sieht es da überhaupt nicht mehr aus.
Das gibt es alles in der Form nicht mehr.
Guck hier, man hat das komplette Gewicht im Fahrstuhl hängen hier hinten.
Ne, man sieht es gar nicht.
Also, das ist ja nicht nur das Kabel für die Elektrik gewesen.
Hier unten war halt so ein Stahlseil.
Also, man muss ja sagen, mein Opa, da war schon echt big brain, was das angeht.
Wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt.
Gehen wir hier mal rein da.
Anderer Raum, hier gehe ich rein.
Habt ihr die Bilder beiden klar? Jaja.
Guck mal hier, das war das Atelier vom Opa.
Guckt euch mal an, wie viele Bilder der hier am Start hatte.
Okay, ja, ich hätte, das iPhone damals hatte nicht mehr FPS.
Das heißt, Kameraschwänks erkennt man nicht, gut.
Was er, wie er jung war, was er gerne gemalt hat, nackte Weiber.
Monkathos, Monkathos.
Monkathos.
Hatte der eigentlich immer Damen zu Besuch, die er gemalt hat?
Ja, meistens schon.
Meistens, meistens schon.
Sogar, wo der mit meiner Oma schon verheiratet war, hatte der auch Damen zu Besuch, die sich hermalen lassen.
Ich frag mich echt, was meine Oma davon hielte, gehalten hat.
Vor allem, ich meine, die waren ja dann auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Also, keine Ahnung, ich stell dir mal vor, du bist irgendwie 50 oder so.
Und dein Kerl, der hat da irgendwie 25-jährige Mädels oben im Atelier, Tür ist zu und die werden gemalt.
Ich hätte mir da an der Stelle von meiner Oma Gedanken gemacht, aber anscheinend war das kein Problem.
Irgendwelche Wasserfarben-Sachen liegen hier dann auch rum.
Ja, aber guck mal, der hat auch noch mehr nackte Weiber, das hat ja gar nicht mehr auf, Alter.
Guck mal, sogar mein Opa selbst hier, da ist er.
Da ist er.
Noch mehr, das hat ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Das bin ich hier hinten, wie ich kleiner war.
Kleiner Max ist da auch dabei.
War dein Opa hauptberuflich Künstler oder als Hobby?
Der hat das...
Früher hat er es als Hobby gemacht, später hat er es mehr oder weniger hauptberuflich gemacht.
League, ja.
Das fand ich lustig, ey.
Wenn du oben durch das Atelier vom Opa gegangen bist,
dann hast du echt, das hat gefühlt zu 30-40% aus nackten Mädels bestanden, die Bilder.
Jetzt wissen wir, wie Max in ein paar Jahren aussieht.
Ne, so werde ich wahrscheinlich aussehen.
Jaja.
So, mit was fangen wir denn an?
Wieder ein Stream.
Yes.
Excellent.
Ja, ich habe die letzten Tage ein bisschen Zeug gespielt mal wieder.
Übrigens, ich habe morgen gar nicht frei.
Ich habe morgen Big Brain Schulung Azure DevOps.
Ja.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Aber nicht bei denen, irgendwo anders.
Eine 5-tägige Microsoft Azure DevOps-Schulung.
Das wird, ich weiß jetzt schon, dass das wahrscheinlich zu,
mal locker zur Hälfte, extrem langweilig wird.
Ich hoffe, es sind ein paar Sachen dabei, die was taugen.
Die meisten Azure-Schulungen sind HyperResident Sleeper.
Und das liegt daran, weil die Schulungsleute nicht einfach eine Schulung machen
und den Leuten was beibringen wollen,
sondern die müssen sich alle an so einem komischen Microsoft-Material abarbeiten.
Also sprich, die haben da mehr oder weniger ein paar vorgefertigte PowerPoint-Dinger,
dass es eben halt standardisiert ist.
Und dann ist es im Prinzip nur runtergeratter.
Das ist übelst langweilig.
Wozu braucht man da für eine Schulung?
Eigentlich gar nicht.
Um das Papier? Nee, nee.
Also, du könntest die Schulung als, ähm,
Dings, wie er heißt, Zertifikatsvorbereitung machen,
aber ich mache kein Zertifikat.
Wozu soll ich ein Zertifikat machen?
Zertifikat Monarch S.
Ich mache kein Zertifikat.
Wie heißt du damals noch auf YouTube?
Tja, das ist die Frage.
Nur Oldschool-Leute wissen das.
Haha.
Oh nee, er hat es verraten.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre hier ein Link auf YouTube.
Richtig, NoBadEnergy hat es verraten.
Was wollte ich jetzt noch krasser?
Also, wozu man da eine Schulung braucht,
das ist eine berechtigte Frage hier.
Äh, äh...
Wer hat es gefragt?
Dubstep? Nee.
Dubsteiniel.
Eigentlich braucht man das gar nicht.
Allerdings sind die bei uns gerade so scharf drauf,
dass alle die wahnsinnige Escher-Kompetenz haben.
Und es ist egal, ob man da...
Ach so, jetzt wird es ein bisschen laut, die Musik.
Da kann man nicht entscheiden.
So.
Ähm, dann ist es bei uns auch fast egal,
ob du dich damit auskennst oder nicht.
Die sind so scharf drauf, dass die Leute gerade Schulungen machen.
Und unser Chef war auch am Starten, hat gemeint,
ja, es gibt es jetzt aktuell.
Reduziert die Schulung und sonst was, mach doch mal eine.
Da haben wir uns halt die rausgesucht,
die uns noch am meisten interessiert.
Das taugt halt was.
Wirklich brauchen tut man sie wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil das, was man bisher in den Escher-Schulungen gemacht hat,
hätte man sich eigentlich auch in 1-2 Tagen locker selbst angucken können,
hätte besser durchgeblickt.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es auch wieder so ein Ding,
weil am Ende sitzen da ja irgendwelche Stonks-Leute.
Und wenn dann wahrscheinlich der jeweilige Gruppenteam abteilungs-
was auch immer Leiter sagen kann,
bei mir haben 80% Escher-Schulung gemacht,
dann sagt dann der Stonks-Mann, boah, ihr seid geil.
Ihr kennt euch jetzt richtig, richtig aus
und seid richtig exzellent.
Und wer sich wirklich auskennt, darum geht es, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Es geht eher darum, dass es gut aussieht.
Irgendwas hat doch vorhin einer geschickt, was wir uns angucken sollen.
Das da.
Wie sicher ist die Corona-App?
Oje, oje, oje, oje.
Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Ist das Video in Juni?
Moment, das ist ein Monat alt.
Das kenne ich, das ist uralt, das Video.
Das ist überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell.
Mittlerweile gibt es noch mehr Sachen, oder?
Mittlerweile gibt es doch sogar schon irgendeine Analyse,
was Backend-mäßig angeht.
Also, das ist doch gar nicht mehr aktuell.
Aber ihr könnt es trotzdem gucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Ich bin ja mal auf den Chat gespannt.
Der Chat ist bestimmt voll mit Monka-Corona-Sachen.
Also von Bill Gates.
Also im Chat würde ich jetzt erwarten, von Bill Gates.
Wir gucken mal kurz durch, was da alles im Chat so gekommen ist.
Von Bill Gates bis sonst was.
Ich weiß nicht viele, aber wenn sie nicht auf dem So-
Ist sie doch.
Könnt ihr behalten den Dreck.
Scheiß Stasi-Stas-
Der Chat, Alter.
Das sieht doch aus.
By the way, ich hab die Corona-App nicht installiert.
Weißt du auch warum?
Weil so oft mein Handy nicht funktioniert.
Kann man nichts machen.
Das ist noch harmlos.
Ja klar, das geht noch schlimmer.
Nee, aber das lohnt sich, glaube ich, nicht wirklich anzugucken.
Das Video ist ein Monat alt.
Es ist viel spannender sich anzugucken.
Es gab letztens doch so eine Analyse,
was auch Serverinfrastruktur und sowas angeht.
Die ist viel neuer, das ist erst ein paar Tage alt.
Wieso heute so früh?
Jetzt wird sich schon besperrt, dass ich früher am Start bin.
Kegweight.
Man muss-
Ich hab letztens was auf YouTube gefunden.
Und zwar-
Wie heißt das?
Twitch chat people emotes.
Moment, Moment.
Explained.
Hier, hier.
Ups.
Ups, nice, das Video.
Von dem haben wir schon mal was geguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das nicht mehr Viewer hat.
Aber von dem haben wir schon mal das hier geguckt.
Von dem haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Story of Lulvee vs. Kegwee.
Das haben wir schon mal geguckt hier.
Aber ich dachte damals, ich hab mich damals schon gewundert,
warum das so wenig Views hat.
Und ich wundere mich immer noch, warum das so wenig Views hat.
Weil allein schon der Anfang sollte dafür sorgen,
dass es 800.000 Views hat.
Allein schon der Anfang.
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt von ihm mal erklären,
how to Twitch chat people emotes.
Ah, yes.
Mokratos.
Poggo hab ich nicht.
Ich versteh den Sinn von Poggo gar nicht.
Ich find das irgendwie total bescheuert.
Es gibt für alle anderen irgendwelche Poggeemotes.
Wozu braucht man Poggo?
Aber vielleicht kriegen wir das ja erklärt.
Was war das?
He's lacking critical information.
He lacks critical information, genau.
Ah, yes.
Mal gucken, ob er auch Pepo Planket hat.
Ah, nee, doch nicht.
Haben wir das?
Haben wir das enabled?
Haben wir nicht.
Doch, haben wir.
Haben wir.
Oldschool.
Emote, jetzt habt ihr das gehört.
Ah, exellent.
Blanket.
Ah.
Okay, hier kriegt man richtig beigebracht,
wie man den Twitch Chat verwendet.
Ich hab Peposet immer falsch verwendet.
Okay, hier kriegt man richtig beigebracht,
wie man den Twitch Chat verwendet.
Ich hab Peposet immer falsch verwendet.
Weeps out kommt an.
Peter.
Ich würde Pepehands nehmen.
Das stimmt.
Penobel ist unterwegs.
Habe ich glaube ich gar nicht aktiviert.
Genau, Pepehands, wir haben was Neues.
Das stimmt, hab ich gestern aktiviert.
Ich muss sagen, mein Pepehands ist mehr High-Res als sein Pepehands.
Pinnishdorf hab ich auch nicht aktiviert.
Overheat, Overheat ist das.
Ich bin ja, ich frag mich ja immer, was mit mir los ist.
Warum erkenne ich die Emotes schon, wenn sie nur schwarz-weiß sind?
Also in dem Fall, ich kenn das Video schon,
aber ich hab's am Anfang auch erkannt.
Das eins davon ist Pepeoverheat, oder wie das heißt.
Genau.
Warum erkenne ich das schon schwarz-weiß?
Das ist der Pepeoverheat-Pinnschamp.
Ich war letztens in irgendeinem Stream, ich weiß gar nicht wo es war.
Und da hat der Streamer gesagt, Don't Pog Yet.
Und der Chat hat dann irgendwie, danach hat er es wieder vergessen.
Und der Chat hat 10 Minuten lang gespammt, I Can't Hold It.
Das ist so richtig dämlich.
Und dann irgendwann haben sie angefangen alle rumzuspammen, Can We Pog Yet?
Und irgendwann hat er dann gesagt, Now You Can Pog.
Und dann hat der Chat 10 Minuten Pog gespammt.
Richtig hängen gebliebenes Twitch-Zeugs.
Aber deswegen mag ich Twitch.
Sag mal, kann mir irgendjemand erklären, ich hab mitgekriegt,
irgendwie gab es die letzten Tage bei Knossi ein Angelcamp oder sowas.
Und ganz Twitter-Deutschland hat das voll abgefeiert.
Das hat irgendwie 300.000 Viewer auf Twitch.
Und ich hab das 2-mal angemacht, 3-mal angemacht.
Das erste Mal waren das irgendwelche Leute, die manche von kennt,
auf einem Campingplatz, die haben auf Stühlen gesessen und irgendwie Zeug gelabert.
Das nächste Mal haben die im Dunkeln auf dem Campingplatz gesessen und irgendwie Zeug gelabert.
Und Knossi hat halt seinen typischen Knossi-Talk gemacht.
Dann war irgendwann Sido am Start, hat irgendwie 2 Sachen gesungen.
So, okay, also das hab ich davor mitgekriegt.
Und irgendwie wird das jetzt als der neue Ship gefeiert,
so nach dem Motto, Fernseh ist out, Twitch beste und so.
Und ich verstehe nicht, warum. Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Für mich sah das so aus wie RTL nur auf Twitch.
Aber ich bin da entweder zu alt oder zu low-brain für...
Also ich verstehe die Begeisterung nicht.
Reality TV für Zoomer, okay. Ja, genau so wirkte das auf mich auch.
Also ich kann die Begeisterung nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Es wirkt wie mitten im Leben oder so.
Es wirkt wie RTL auf Twitch, ja.
Was warte, was ist mit Sido passiert?
Der sitzt mit Knossi und wer ist noch dabei? Knossi, unsympathisch, TV...
Keine Ahnung, wer da alles dabei ist.
In irgendeinem Camp und die labern halt da den ganzen Tag.
Hier, das da meine ich, Twitch-Angel-Camp.
Wo ist es? Nee, nee, Quitch-Knossi muss man suchen.
Und ich verstehe nicht, was die alle daran so geil finden.
Okay, das Camp ist wohl vorbei.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, das wirkt für mich wie RTL auf Twitch
und ich verstehe die Begeisterung nicht.
Na gut, aber wie jeder wieder mag, ja.
Was war eigentlich mit der Geschichte...
Ja, Haftbefehl hat sich selbst angeschossen.
Da musste ich auch kecken, Alter.
Haftbefehl, Krankenhaus.
Ja, Haftbefehl hat sich irgendwelche Drogen eingeschmissen,
hat sich aus Versehen selbst angeschossen.
Da musste ich echt eine Runde lachen, als ich das gelesen habe.
Rapper Haftbefehl schießt sich aus Versehen ins Beine.
Na ja.
Das auch immer.
Irgendwie fand ich es lustig.
Doch nicht genug Gangsters da am Start.
Ja, wer kennt es nicht?
Wer schießt sich nicht aus Versehen in den Bein?
Ach ja, ergeblich war er in Frankfurt irgendwo im Bahnhofsviertel.
Das passt ja noch mehr.
Was? Moment, was war die Frage?
Ja, da gebe ich dir Recht.
Aber es ist das Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Eine Idee, wie ich meinen Raspberry Pi mit Retopie starten kann,
ohne manuell Strom aus anzumachen.
Wake on LAN? Vielleicht?
Wake on LAN?
Oder, oder, keine Ahnung.
Wake on WLAN?
Gibt es sowas?
Blöde Frage. Gibt es Wake on WLAN?
Okay, anscheinend gibt es sowas.
Exzellent. Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Wake on WLAN? Wie wäre es mit Wake on WLAN?
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Ja, aber Wake on LAN sollte so das Klassische sein.
Ich meine, du kannst natürlich auch sowas hier nehmen,
was ich mir da auf AliExpress bestellt habe.
Dafür, Moment, AliExpress.
Oh fuck, wie hieß dieses Ding?
WF, Wi-Fi, USB, Switch oder so?
Ach du Scheiße.
USB, Switch.
WF. Ah hier, da war es doch, WF.
Hier, den da.
Du kannst natürlich auch sowas da bestellen
und Custom Firmware flashen.
Dann hast du ein Webinterface,
wo du dann Raspberry Pi quasi Strom an- und ausschalten kannst.
Das kannst du auch machen, wenn Wake on LAN nicht geht.
Kostet nur 4,30 Euro per AliExpress.
Kannst du flashen, da ist Motor drauf
und dann hast du ein Webinterface,
wo du quasi die USB Stromversorgung ein- und ausschalten kannst.
Kannst du auch manuell ein- und ausschalten.
Aber ich wollte das Video fertig gucken.
Wo waren wir denn jetzt?
So, auf Jelly sage ich gleich was zu.
Oh, Besse.
Ah ja.
XQC Speaker.
Man muss ja sagen, man muss ja sagen,
Twitch International, ja.
Da ist auch schon ziemlich viel dummes Zeugs dabei.
So ist es nicht.
Ich finde das meist irgendwie noch nicht so low-brain lustig,
sondern es ist halt teilweise einfach wirklich lustig.
Ich habe mir beispielsweise auch wirklich lang XQC angeguckt.
Ich kann mir den aktuell allerdings nicht mehr angucken.
Das liegt weniger an XQC selbst, sondern eben am Chat.
Der Chat ist mittlerweile zu gespamme.
Da ist keinerlei Witz mehr im Chat bei XQC.
Das war, als er noch ein bisschen weniger Viewer hat, nicht ganz so schlimm.
Aber Twitch Deutschland entwickelt sich glaube ich jetzt eher zu RTL.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Habt ihr das E-Mode schon jemals gesehen?
Ich kenne das nicht.
Und ich bin viel auf Twitch unterwegs.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Äh, noch nie gesehen.
Was ist das, die kenne ich nicht.
Also wenn ich das sehen würde, dann ist das für mich eindeutig eher MonkaS.
Coggers, beste!
Viel zu underused, Coggers.
Coggers ist das beste.
Coggers.
Ok, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Jetzt haben wir die Pipe, wie Pepe Emotes gelernt.
Und ihr wisst ja, eigentlich geht das überhaupt nicht.
Weil, allein schon Pepe Emotes zu verwenden ist ja eigentlich Hate Speech.
Weiß man ja heute.
Also Pepe ist ja offiziell ein Hasssymbol mittlerweile.
Wie auch immer.
2020, Alter.
Die Welt hat sie nicht mehr alle.
Yep.
Hasssymbol, ja.
Genauso, genauso wie das Ok.
Genauso wie das Ok Emoji.
Das ist immer...
Ich glaube, das Ok Emoji.
Also das da, Ok Hand Emoji.
Ich glaube, das ist der einzige Troll von 4chan, den 4chan jetzt selbst bereut.
Normalerweise...
Also wer das nicht kennt, mal kurz zur Erklärung.
Das hier ist ein ganz normales Emoji.
Bedeutet in der Regel eigentlich immer Ok.
Also in ganz vielen Bereichen der Welt.
Nicht in allen, aber meistens ist irgendwas Positives mit der Verbindung.
Irgendwie ok, passt schon, ja.
Und 4chan hat dann getrollt und die Presse hat aufgegriffen, dass das angeblich für Wild Power steht.
So, und nachdem sich das jetzt so durchgesetzt hat, ist für viele das jetzt auf einmal Wild Power anstatt Ok Hand.
Im Prinzip ist es ein stinknormaler 4chan Troll, wie alles, wie vieles, wie vieles andere auch, ja.
Aber ich glaube, das ist der einzige 4chan Troll, den 4chan selber bereut, weil es zu ausgeufert ist.
Und jetzt ein stinknormales Emoji auf einmal Hate Speech ist.
Arschloch in Italien, ja.
Ja, passt ja von der Bezeichnung, ja.
Kann man sich auch vorstellen, ja.
Also...
Also, ich glaube, das ist einer der wenigen 4chan Trolls, die 4chan selber bereut, das Ok Hand zu Wild Power umzudichten.
Ja.
Aber allein schon, dass das funktioniert, sieht man mal, dass die Leute heute ein bisschen Dachschaden haben allesamt.
Also wenn Pepe ein Hate Symbol ist und das Ok Emoji auf einmal für Wild Power steht.
Und wisst ihr was?
Boah, WTF.
Ich rauche doch gar nicht.
Ja.
Und wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist mittlerweile?
Dass es jetzt tatsächlich irgendwelche rechten Nazi, was auch immer Gruppierungen es gibt, die tatsächlich jetzt das Ok Hand Emoji in diesem Kontext verwenden.
Es ist Hardcore Monarch S.
Das ist richtig dämlich.
Als erstes ist es ein ganz normales Emoji, dann trollt 4chan und dann greifen das noch irgendwelche Brain Dead Rechten auf und benutzen das auch noch.
Es ist so unglaublich dämlich, die Welt 2020.
Naja.
Motorize Roller Shape. Brauche ich nicht, habe ich schon.
Ok, was können wir uns sonst noch angehen? How to Twitch Chat haben wir jetzt schon geguckt.
2020 halt, ja aber echt.
Slow Motion.
Sowas gucke ich mir normalerweise nicht an, aber das Vorschaubild sah eigentlich ganz cool aus.
Alpa HD.
Also Pepe Love kann man nicht so verwenden, das geht nicht.
Da musst du noch dahinter schreiben, he lacks critical information.
Nur dann ist das offiziell erlaubt auf Twitch.
Ghost of Tsushima Review.
Das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken, ich glaube das hier war das.
Wir gucken uns tatsächlich das Ghost of Tsushima Review an.
Weil da bin ich gespannt was da rausgekommen ist.
Mal gucken wer das macht.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe es ist Dimitri oder Maurice. Mal gucken wer das Review macht.
Nein, ok ich habe keine Ahnung wer das ist.
Anne-Kathrin Kuhls.
Zu leise.
Grill Review.
Was war das, was war das?
Ein Granatenpfeil.
Alles klar.
Der fliegt ja auch so gerade.
Egal.
Game für Sebaro.
Ey in der Mongolei ist gestern einer an der Beulenpest gestorben habe ich in den News gelesen.
Irgendwie passt das gerade zum Thema, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass 2020 Leute noch an der Beulenpest sterben.
Was sagen wir jetzt?
Educational Stream heute wieder.
Was, warum, das frage ich mich bei Assassin's Creed Valhalla auch.
Was ist diese Besessenheit der Entwickler oder auch Filmemacher von Feuerfeilen?
Was finden die alle an Feuerfeilen so toll?
Man sieht sie.
Man könnte es einfach am Tag spielen lassen.
Ok, die Gegner sind ja richtig big brain.
Ich sehe schon, das ist Gameplay, wo ich mich ein bisschen daran abreagieren kann.
Guck mal, jetzt überleg mal, die Gegner sind sehr big brain.
Da kommt die Kavallerie auf sie zu geritten und was machen sie?
Einfach schön breit nebeneinander mit einem Schwert in der Hand warten, bis der Reiter sie umreitet.
Exzellent, genauso würde ich das auch machen.
Ich meine, Alternative wäre, sich vielleicht in Formation stellen mit einem Speer oder so.
Aber nein, nein, nein, das geht nicht.
Das ist aber ziemlich low brain.
Oh, kein Ehrenmann.
Ist das, ist das Hanzo?
Ist das Hanzo?
Moment.
Nicht Hanzo, Hanzo Voice Actor.
Wie heißt der Typ hier?
Ghost of Tsushima, wie auch immer man das schreibt.
Ja, das ist Hanzo.
Also nicht der Held, der andere Dude.
Wen spricht der da, Ghosts?
Additional Characters, ok, irgendwelche Nebencharakter.
Das andere ist Hanzo, hört euch das mal an.
Also nicht der, der andere.
Der hier.
Das ist Hanzo.
Big Brain Voice Analyse.
Alter, was ist das für ein Riesentyp?
Jetzt schreckt.
Also der richtige Ayayaya Style wäre jetzt eigentlich gewesen.
Der müsste jetzt eigentlich in zwei Hälften zersplittern und Blut rausspritzen in der Mitte.
Und ganz wichtig, er müsste vorher noch irgendwie sowas sagen wie What?
Der hätte genau Easykiller, der hätte 10 Sekunden länger in der Pose bleiben müssen, dann auch irgendwie sowas sagen wie What?
Und dann in zwei Hälften zersplittern.
In your face.
Ja, es passiert ihm ja gar nichts.
Der Gegner braucht auch drei Stunden bis er drauf schlägt, oder?
Der Gegner liegt vor mir, was mache ich jetzt?
Ich könnte draufschauen, ich drehe ihn nochmal und jetzt überlege ich, jetzt überlege ich, jetzt überlege ich, jetzt schlage ich mal drauf.
Big Brain Gegner.
Excellent.
Deutschland 2020, Alter.
Man muss das Blut immer noch ausstellen für Review Videos.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Fast.
Ah, Assassin Wishing.
Assassino.
Die haben auch so ein bisschen dieses Assassin's Creed Slide System, wo du von Gegner zu Gegner slidest, ohne dass du was machen musst.
Sieht zumindest so aus.
Lul, NAA.
Je nachdem wie das gemacht ist, kann fehlendes Lock-on gar nicht so schlecht sein, weil wenn du quasi Gegner Lock-on hast, das lädt dazu ein, einfach sinnlos Attacks zu spammen, bis der Gegner umfällt.
So nach dem Motto, du kannst jetzt entweder eine geile Combo machen oder fünfmal den Standard Attack drücken.
Und mit Lock-on drücken die Leute einfach fünfmal Standard Attack.
Oder es lädt zumindest dazu ein, also je nachdem wie das gemacht ist, muss es gar nicht schlecht sein.
Hm.
So affig gewesen, diese Zwischen-Release-Geschichte.
Oh, man muss auch craften, wie es aussieht.
Ja, es wäre schon nicht schlecht, wenn sie links und rechts die gleiche Szene genommen hätten.
Ja, das stimmt.
Oh, das sieht echt gut aus.
Das sieht wirklich sehr hübsch aus.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist quasi die Sache für Open-World-Spiele, was sie als erstes immer hinkriegen, dass es coole Landschaftsszenen gibt.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal Witcher 3 von irgendeinem Turm an, das sieht auch richtig geil aus, obwohl das Spiel schon irgendwie, wie alt ist Witcher 3, 5 Jahre oder so?
Ja, das sieht echt gut aus.
Oh.
Ja gut, heute haben die Leute aber nicht genug Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, um zwei Minuten von einer Quest zur nächsten Quest zu reiten, das geht nicht.
Also in Zeiten, das müsste eigentlich direkt jump-cuttet werden, Quest fertig, bam, nächste Quest.
Sonst denken sich die Leute, ach nee, ich gehe jetzt lieber auf Twitch-Angelcamp gucken, bevor ich zwei Minuten zur nächsten Quest reite.
Deine Mutter.
Und das ist die letzte Karte, wie sie viele aus Assassin's Creed kennen.
Statt uns mit einem riesen Haufen Quests zu überrumpeln, sind die Aufgaben wohlgewählt und dienen immer dazu, uns mehr in die Welt der Traditionen und Folklore von Tsushima eintauchen zu lassen.
Meistens gibt es außerdem ein Ausrüstungsstück oder eine Technik als Belohnung, die uns wirklich weiterbringt.
Folgen wir beispielsweise den Gerüchten über eine sagenhafte Katana-Technik, die Blitze auf die Erde fallen lassen soll, treffen wir auf diesen freundlichen, inmitten von Leichen sitzenden, alten Mann.
Der erzählt uns nicht nur die Legende hinter der Technik, sondern weist uns auch den Weg zu einem gefährlichen Krieger, der alles dransetzt, sie zu lernen und jeden tötet, der sich ihm in den Weg stellt.
Als Samurai können wir sinnlosen Mord natürlich nicht dulden und setzen ihm nach.
Wie das Ganze ausgeht, verraten wir euch hier zwar nicht, aber die mehrteilige Nebenaufgabe hat uns definitiv bei der Stange gehalten.
Weil die Missionen immer wie sinnvolle Ergänzungen anstatt sinnfreier Fehler wirken, wirkt auch das Spiel sinnvoll kompakt und nicht künstlich aufgebläht.
Selbst sammelbare Crafting-Items wie Bambus, Blumen oder Hölzer sind nicht aufdringig überall und können sogar vom Pferd...
Jedes Game braucht Crafting mittlerweile.
...daus in Windeseile eingesammelt werden. Das solltet ihr definitiv tun, denn mit ihnen lassen sich Rüstungen, Waffen und Gadgets verbessern.
Dadurch, dass Ressourcen relativ sparsam verteilt sind, freut ihr euch über jeden Gesammel-
Okay, hoffentlich muss man nicht auch noch irgendwie Sachen kochen und Nahrungsmittel einsammeln und sowas.
Manche Games übertreiben es mittlerweile echt.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche neuen Games, die einfach, keine Ahnung, eine Story haben und linear sind und ohne links und rechts gedönnt?
...Bambus und nutzen sofort, um damit eure Waffen aufzubessern.
Am besten jetzt noch Skill-Trees und XP.
...und die mehrlichen Verbesserungen motivieren dazu, mit offenen Augen über die Insel zu reiten.
Ebenfalls merklich zum flüssigen Spielfluss beigetragen haben die Nebenfiguren, die nicht nur ausdrucksstark animiert wurden, sondern auch wirklich spannende Geschichten zu erzählen haben.
Während es natürlich Cachet-Figuren wie einen einsam lebenden Sensei oder ein strenges Familienoberhaupt gibt, sind die Geschichten, die hinter diesen Figuren stecken, vielschichtig und meist nicht das, was sie auf den ersten Blick scheinen.
Wir zeigen euch übrigens aus Spoilergründen niemand wichtigen.
Einen guten Eindruck der Animation bietet dieser Mönch aber auch.
Und auch er ist nicht das, was er zu sein scheint.
Aber warum, erfahrt ihr erst im Spiel.
Wenn euch viele der Geschichten wegen der Art ihrer Dialoge, der Dramaturgie oder der Inszenierung an alte Samurai-Filme erinnern, liegt ihr damit Gold richtig.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab noch nie alte Samurai-Filme geguckt. Ich kann das überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
Saka Punch Studios ließen sich vom berühmten Filmemacher Akira Kurosawa inspirieren, der das Genre nachhaltig geprägt hat.
Deswegen wirken viele der Cutscenes in Sachen Farbgebung und Kameraführung filmischer als viele andere Action-Spiele.
Teil dieser Ästhetik sind übrigens auch die vagen Ladungen an Kirschblüten, Ahorn oder goldbrauner Ginko-Blätter, die in vielen der Cutscenes durchs Bild flattern.
Im Fotoeditor könnt ihr sogar die Intensität der Blätter einstellen, falls euch im Spiel noch nicht genug davon umordnet.
Das reicht nicht. Zu wenig.
Gibt es so etwas wie zu viele Ahorn-Blätter oder bedeutet mehr Ahorn nur mehr Stimmung?
Wer es übrigens ganz besonders filmisch haben will, kann im Kurosawa-Modus das Spiel in schwarz-weiß-körnigem Glanz erstrahlen.
Ah na, das muss nicht sein.
Als handelt es sich um Filme in den 50ern.
Männer, wir müssen den Anführer erledigen! Männer, mir nach!
Ja, aber dann vielleicht mit nicht deutscher Synchro.
Also wenn du es authentisch im Original haben willst, dann halt nicht mit deutscher Synchro.
Also das beißt sich irgendwie.
... wäre das Kurosawas Filme ausgemacht hätte. Aber viele seiner Werke erschienen in einer Zeit, in der das technisch das bestmögliche war.
Wenn ihr also den Flair alter Filme erleben wollt, geht das auch.
Nur die Ginko-Blätter verlieren dann natürlich ihren güldenden Glanz.
Spaß beiseite. Wir haben absolut nichts gegen die Ginko-Blätter.
Wo war denn der Spaß?
Weil sie genau über die Figuren und die Inszenierung zur Atmosphäre des Spiels beitragen.
Und es zwischen seinen Genre-Kollegen eindeutig hervorstechen lassen.
Also...
Also ich muss sagen, optisch gefilmt, finde ich es echt hübsch gemacht.
Ansonsten ist es halt mal wieder ein weiteres Open-World-Game in einer Welt, wo jeder meint, er muss Open-World-Games machen.
Also ich brauche nicht noch mehr Open-World-Games. Das habe ich schon 20.000 Mal gesagt, aber gut.
Heißt das nicht, dass es schlecht ist?
Hm. Okay.
Exzellent.
Ähm...
Ich hätte gerne mehr Singleplayer-Story-Games zum Beispiel.
Mit ordentlicher Story.
Aber halt irgendwas mit rotem Faden ohne Open-World.
Übrigens, SirOfJelly hat vorhin irgendwas gefragt, wozu ich was sagen wollte, habe ich ganz vergessen.
Wo war das denn, Sir? Jetzt habe ich mir nur noch gemerkt, dass der... Irgendwo?
Ein Kollege hat mir erzählt, keiner schreibt mehr HTML.
Und das ist alles vorher gereinert, stimmt? Hä?
Jeder schreibt HTML? Wer sagt denn sowas, SirOfJelly? Wer erzählt denn so einen Blödsinn?
Totaler Schwachsinn.
Der Trend ist sogar eher umgedreht.
Der Trend ist sogar eher umgedreht, dass die meisten Sachen mittlerweile, oder viele Sachen mittlerweile, Kleinzeit gemacht werden und dort gerendert werden.
Surfer-Site-Rendering... Also HTML ist es letztendlich immer, was hinten rauskommt. Aber diese Surfer-Site-Rendering-Geschichte ist eigentlich eher auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Ne, also das ist... Also ich weiß nicht, was dein Kollege da noch sonst zu gesagt hat, aber es ist totaler Blödsinn.
Ne, also das ergibt keinen Sinn, was der da erzählt.
Ist das PS4 Exclusive? Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, das ist PS4 Exclusive. Wahrscheinlich kommt es in einem Jahr dann auf dem PC oder sowas.
Das ist PS4 Exclusive, ja.
Hast du eigentlich Festplatten oder SSDs in deinem Nass? Beides, beides.
Ich meine, 12TB in SSDs wäre ein bisschen teuer.
Ich habe eine 500G-Platte fürs System und ein bisschen was. Ein bisschen Zeug drinne. Und der Rest sind 12TB Festplatte.
Klassische Magnet-Festplatte.
Mein dummes Huhnchen.
So, was können wir sonst noch so angucken jetzt?
Wir müssen eine Runde Battlefield gucken. Irgendwie müssen wir jetzt eine Runde Battlefield gucken.
20 Minutes of best Battlefield for infantry players. Excellent.
Hast du dir das HyperMirror mal im Discord? Ne, habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Was denn? Schick mal Link, wir können uns hier angucken.
12TB Games aufnehmen? Ne, die Spiele nehme ich, also Gameplay nehme ich nicht aufs Nass auf.
Gameplay nehme ich auf meine zweite Festplatte, also auf meine vierte Festplatte oder was das ist vom Laufwerk her.
Hier mein Rechner auf und die Sachen, die ich behalten will, schiebe ich dann aufs Nass.
Also es reicht ja dann auch. Muss man nicht direkt live drauf schreiben.
Muss also eine Runde Battlefield geben. Das finde ich immer sehr entspannend, sonntag morgens.
Der sagt echt jedes Mal das gleiche und ich sage jedes Mal das gleiche, dass er das gleiche sagt.
Können wir uns danach angucken?
Moment, das ist Battlefield, ne ach ne, das ist Battlefield 4 Metro?
Das ist Battlefield 4 oder? Ne, ist das Battlefield 3?
Das sieht eher nach, ne das ist Battlefield 3, das ist erstens sieht man das hier am Plaustich und an der Minimap.
Naja, weil er hier oben, ich war verwirrt, weil hier oben steht 20 minutes best Battlefield 4 infantry players und das ist Battlefield 3.
Könntest du Youtube ein bisschen lauter machen? Ich mach den absichtlich nicht lauter, weil ich laber immer drüber und der sagt jedes Mal das gleiche.
Ja das stimmt. Ich bin begeistert, wie sich Leute heute noch an der Metro Treppe abfarben lassen.
Hi, wie steht ihr so zu 21 zu 9 Monitoren? Ist ne coole Sache zum Arbeiten. Auf der Arbeit habe ich auch einen 21 zu 9 curved Monitor, das ist nice.
Daheim eher nicht, weil daheim spiele ich ja hauptsächlich, also daheim arbeite ich und spiele ich. Also da ist ein 21 zu 9 find ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig toll.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man auf viel FPS steht. Wenn man normal viel FPS auskommt, wenn man vielleicht sogar nur 60 FPS im Durchschnitt haben will, dann kann man sich natürlich auch die fette Auflösung und 21 zu 9 gönnen.
Aber wer quasi 144 240 Hz Multiplayer spielt, der kann das schlicht und ergreifend auf 21 zu 9 gar nicht richtig machen.
Bester Name. 1200 RPM Piu Piu Piu. Klingt irgendwie ziemlich 3-Head.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Aber nichts geht über die M16 in dem Spiel.
Die werden aber ganz schön gerecht, die Gegner gerade.
Und die Gegner sind wieder absolut brain. Was macht der da in der Ecke?
Sitzt er auf dem Klo und wartet, dass er reinkommt oder?
Ah locker.
Die Waffe ist extrem beliebt in Clips. Ich hab.
Moment. Das ist nicht die, die ich immer gespielt habe. Ich habe die ACR gespielt. Die ACR habe ich immer gespielt. Vielleicht soll ich es mal ausprobieren wieder.
Boah, da geht es aber ab um den Drumme rum.
Das ist übrigens absichtlich, dass er so hoch und runter gesprungen ist. Da zappelst du bei den Gegnern richtig rum.
Dadurch, dass Battlefield versucht seine Bewegungen so ein bisschen zu interpolieren.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht noch aus den alten Battlefields, wenn du immer so über den Hindernis drüber gesprungen bist.
Dann ging es oftmals so, das Spiel wollte, dass du quasi drüber springst, Animation machst und Wirklichkeit hat das Game so gemacht.
Es hat dich hier gezeichnet und dann hat es dich da wieder registriert und du bist hier quasi flüpp drüber gewesen.
Ich glaube, das hat er versucht gerade mit seinem Movement hier auch zu machen.
Flame Haze, ich fürchte. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es nochmal hinbekommen.
Ich lasse mich aber gerne positiv überraschen mit dem nächsten Battlefield.
With a 12 man streak on Seas of Shanghai using the SV-98 and limited HUD as well.
So the game looks extra special. Battlefield 4 being a game that did come out in 2013.
But it could easily pass as a game that has come out maybe in the last year or two.
Amazing stuff using the SV-98.
Battlefield 4 sieht richtig gut aus.
Killing enemies at all sorts of ranges on this amazing...
Das ist Hardcore-Server.
Da sieht ihn keiner, ne?
The absolute low-brain-igste Gegner.
Das ist kein Hardcore-Server, da wäre er schon down.
Wow, dass er den gehitet hat. Also die zwei Kills waren nice.
Okay, Gegner mit der absolute brain...
Was soll der machen, ja?
Was soll der machen?
Er hat's kommen sehen.
Und jetzt durch den Smoke spotten und alles wegklatschen.
Der wollte ihn messern, habt ihr das gesehen?
Der hat gerade die Messer-Animation gestartet.
Null.
Scheint beliebt zu sein. LMG, Schalldämpfer und...
Die Gegner haben echt wieder das Gewehr falsch rum.
Gut, mein aktuell schießt er nur in eine Richtung.
Das kriege ich auch noch hin.
Wie aktiv ist Battlefield 3 auf dem PC? Geht, kann man ohne Probleme noch spielen.
Haben wir die letzten paar Wochen auch ein paar Mal gemacht.
So, mal gucken, jetzt muss ja noch irgendwie der Top-Play kommen.
Also da kommt man echt schwer raus. Guckt euch das mal an, da steht ja alles voll.
Oh, Grenade. Nice. Das war cooles Movement.
Natürlich G18, was sonst, ja.
Metro 64 ist ja auch nicht spielbar.
Denkst du Battlefield schafft wieder ein Comeback?
Äh, nee. Ehrlich gesagt, nee. Ich würde es mir wünschen und hätte es gerne wieder, aber ich glaube nicht.
Die haben es so krass verschissen mit den letzten zwei Battlefields.
Ich glaube, die sind einfach unfähig mittlerweile.
Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, dass von Battlefield 3, oder 4, oder Bad Company, oder was auch immer,
ist ja wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr da. Vielleicht noch zwei Leute oder so.
Boah, wie sie eben reinrennen von unten. Wahnsinn.
Ich muss sagen, so schlecht fand ich Hardline gar nicht.
Woran Hardline gekrankt hat, ist, dass Hardline keine guten Spielmodi hatte.
Also ob es zu sagen Rush hat gefehlt.
Alter, die lassen sich wieder wegsprayen. Und die treffen wieder nichts.
Also außer er.
Also ich meine, der macht das schon echt gut.
Aber an der Stelle, das war wirklich Big Brain Move jetzt hier. Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht gar nicht allen aufgefallen.
Guck mal hier. Der setzt sich hinter die Kiste, guckt jetzt vor und jetzt siehst du gleich einen Sniper.
Ihr habt jetzt gesehen, hinter ihm war ein Sniper und jetzt geht er ein Stück rechts, dass ihn der Sniper nicht mehr hitten kann.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich guter Play.
Soziopathen Max, ich bin schon lange auf Twitch am Start.
Auf YouTube jetzt in letzter Zeit ein bisschen weniger.
Max, hast du den Monitor auf 720p oder so? Hä? Nee.
Ja natürlich, natürlich. Er war das letzte Mal auch am Start mit dem Shotgun Play.
Alter, ist ja gut. War nicht nur krach.
Das war übrigens die berühmte Battlefield Hit Detection hier.
Passt mal auf.
Äh, hallo?
Ja, das war voll auf dem Arsch.
Guck mal, voll auf dem Arsch.
Mehr drauf sein kannst du nicht.
Aber Hit Detection sagt Nope.
Achso, ich hab 150% Zoom.
Warum? Das kann ich euch gleich zeigen, warum ich 150% Zoom hab.
Really Accurate? Das erste was man sieht ist der Headshot geht vorbei. Jawoll.
Ich hätte den jetzt auch nicht getroffen wahrscheinlich.
Boah, die hat er aber krass weggeschneibert.
Max, kommt jetzt, Alter, schlecht für die Augen.
Zeig es euch gleich, warum ich 150% hab.
Hold it.
Könnt ihr euch noch an die OP Shotgun erinnern?
An die OP M Dings 426 Dart oder was das war?
Wo du über die ganze Map schießen konntest?
Ist das Spanisch?
Oder Italienisch?
Eher Italienisch, oder Spanisch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Nee, eher Spanisch.
Ist das F2000? Oh, die Gegner.
Nee, die Gegner sind schon tot bevor die Granate explodiert ist.
Italienisch, okay.
F2000 wird nicht viel gespielt.
Ah, wenigstens Red Star.
Dieser Jump Reflex den hab ich heute noch in Games.
Wenn ein Gegner auf mich zukommt, erst mal jumpen.
Und am besten hinter irgendeine Kiste oder eine Ecke.
Ja, diesen Jump Reflex, ich weiß auch nicht.
Das ist sowas, das hat man sich angehört.
Was war an der Decke?
Da hängt ein Gasrohr.
Ja, aber warum sollte man da dran schießen?
Okay, Crash Fluffy plus in Valorant ist es glaube ich nicht gut um die Ecke zu springen.
Wegen Accuracy und so.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, nice.
Ich bin ja begeistert, dass es Leute gibt, die Battlefield 3 streamen so richtig,
richtig serious mit Facecam und allem.
Krasser Shit.
Ja, Battlefield 5 ist dead jetzt.
Oh, die Gegner checken nix, aber das ist cool zu sehen.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, boah, geil.
Ich mag so Clips, die einfach 45 Minuten permanentes weggebashe sind.
Ich habe das lieber als irgendwelche aus dem Jet springen, RPG, Crossbow auf den gegnerischen Heli
und dann wieder in Chat springen.
So cool die Dinger sind, sowas gucke ich mir lieber an.
Und er wird natürlich garantiert geflamed, weil Shotgun Noob.
Sobald du Shotgun verwendest, egal wie gut du bist, bist du quasi laut Chat immer Noob.
Nee, das ist nicht Battlefield 4, das ist Battlefield 3.
Das ist Battlefield 3.
Hustelsaft.
Das ist Battlefield 4.
Headshot.
Facebewerbung ist raus.
Warum kriegen die den nicht tot?
Habe ich auch so gut wie nicht gespielt in dem Game.
Aber ich habe halt den Medic Train hochgehalten.
Kennst du noch Zerka?
Sagt mir gerade nichts.
Und ausgerechnet Claymore.
Stimmt.
OP.
Die G18 ist echt OP.
Das Ding ist besser als der SMG.
Gibt es die eigentlich als Single Fire, die G18?
Gibt es die eigentlich als Single Fire?
Oder hat er die auf Single Fire sogar?
Nee, der hat die auf Auto.
Du kannst die auf Single Fire umstellen.
Gut, warum sollte man das machen?
Balance ist da.
Ich fand es gar nicht so schlecht.
Klar, du hattest in Battlefield 3 und in Battlefield 4 schon übelst OP Sachen.
Aber du konntest, meine absolute Lieblingswaffe übrigens in dem Game,
aber du konntest gerade in Battlefield 3 Rush oder auch Battlefield 4 Rush,
du konntest sehr viel über Position und Movement machen.
Und egal, du konntest die schlechteste Waffe der Welt spielen,
wenn du neben den Gegnern standest und die in eine andere Richtung geguckt haben.
G18 Akimbo, ja, aber das war ein anderes Game.
Der Defi piept?
Am Anfang?
Battlefield Play for Free habe ich nie gespielt.
Das war in dieser Battlefield 2 Verschnitt.
In your ass, Alter, die checken es wieder nicht.
Die haben es ja null gecheckt.
Alle spielen auf Deutsch.
Das ist der Recher-Bonus.
VFB, ich gucke ja auch nur Video.
Man erkennt sofort, dass Battlefield 3 ist.
Plaust dich extrem und die Perks unten.
Sehr gut, jeder Mann.
Oh, der war gut.
Dass er den erwischt hat in seiner Kiste ist nicht schlecht.
Guck mal hier.
Der guckt kaum raus.
Den mal so einfach so kurz drauf zu aimen und zu treffen, das ist nicht schlecht.
Das war ziemlich POC-like.
Dieser fette Rat-Dot beim Sniper.
Die rennen ihm auch krass rein, aber trotzdem, das ist echt ein guter Clip.
Dann killt er auch noch Leute mit der USP.
Das ist ein wirklich guter Clip.
Nicht sterben.
Ach, der lebt.
Der wird gehitted und hat auch keinen Bock sich zu bewegen.
Egal, hat eh keinen Sinn mehr.
Schreckt.
Wie der voll mit dem Kopf reingerannt.
Das ist ein echt geiler Clip.
Und jetzt macht er sogar noch, naja nicht lege Henne, äh, Capture Henne.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Jetzt stirbt er.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Äh, ho?
Moment, what, what?
What the fuck?
Haben die sich gerade gegenseitig gemessert?
Die bessern sich gerade gegenseitig.
Das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen.
Ah, er zerplatt.
Oh, Rats.
Suppression, null.
Oh, nice.
Und dann noch ein Headshot, okay, das war Glück, aber trotzdem Pog.
Jetzt einfach mal wild, oh, da war was.
Einfach mal wild in Smoke schießen.
Das ist ja ein mega geiler Clip.
Jetzt wird er übermütig, jetzt wird er übermütig hier.
Jetzt wird, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt wird er übermütig.
Aber huge, huge Clip.
Nice.
Poggers.
So, was kommen wir uns als nächstes an?
Guck, ich habe 30 Milliarden Videos hier.
Äh, Sommo.
Do old viruses work on modern PCs?
Okay.
Können wir uns angucken?
Speed up Windows, ne, ne, ne, das will ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist bestimmt langweilig.
Fünf Dinge, die man mit seinem Router-USB-Port machen kann.
Okay, fünf Dinge.
Den USB-Stick anschließen und das als Ultra-Crap-Nas verwenden.
Ach so, warum 150%?
Ich glaube, ich habe es gar nicht auf 150% hier, doch.
Ähm, weil man dann so im Fullscreen das komplette Video hat inklusive dem Titel.
Deswegen 150%.
Also im, im, im, im Breiten, im Theater-View.
Dann hat man das komplette Video und halt nur den Titel und links.
Deswegen habe ich 150%.
Excellent.
Battlefield 3 startet nicht.
Äh, wenn, wenn du, wenn es, also ich weiß nicht, ob du nicht nur auf die Server joinen kannst.
Weil das liegt manchmal daran, dass Punkbuster nicht läuft.
Okay, was kann man, was kann man für fünf coole Sachen mit seinem Druck, mit seinem Router-Port machen?
Kann USB-Stick anschließen, das als absolut Crap-Nas verwenden.
Man kann vielleicht Firmware-Updates machen über ein USB-Port, vielleicht, vielleicht einen Drucker anschließen.
Mehr fällt mir nicht ein.
Zeig mal her.
Was, was kann man mit seinem Router-Port machen?
Router?
Moment, coole Leute sagen Router.
Router, Router, Router.
What the hell, fuck.
Sellout-Modus activated.
Ja, ja.
Da werde ich auch drauf kommen.
Okay, ah, wir müssen uns das Video nicht angucken.
Ah, der hat, der hat Dings, wir müssen das Video gar nicht gucken.
Okay, Drucken, NAS, Media Server, okay, das kommt aufs gleiche raus.
Backup kommt auch aufs gleiche raus.
Connectivity.
Das sind billig TP-Link-Access-Point, die sehen so aus.
Und das ist ein Dings, ein Netgear.
Ach so, dass man Modem anschließt, meint er damit.
Firmware-Updates, excellent.
Gut, wir mussten das Video nicht gucken, wir wissen, was er macht.
Er druckt, er macht NAS, er macht Firmware-Updates und er schließt ein Modem an.
Excellent.
Wisst ihr, ganz einfach, ohne das Video zu gucken.
What happened to the all-female League of Legends?
Stimmt, was ist eigentlich aus denen geworden, ja.
Vielleicht kann sich da noch irgend einer dran erinnern.
Es gab in der, ich verfolge LoL nicht so sehr, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Deswegen kann sein, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle, welche Leagues das waren.
Aber es gibt ja wohl eine offizielle League of Legends-Liga-Format, so ein bisschen wie OWL wahrscheinlich.
Und soweit ich weiß, gab es dort als einziges ein Female-Team, also ein komplettes Team aus Mädels.
Und auch nur, weil die Orga, wenn ich das jetzt richtig zusammenkriege, dort wo die quasi eingestellt waren,
die hat ihr altes LoL-Team entlassen.
Und die wollten dann einen Werbegag machen und haben einen all-female-Team eingestellt.
Und die haben komplett abgekackt.
Die waren mega schlecht.
Also nein, das stimmt nicht.
Die waren nicht mega schlecht insgesamt gesehen.
Die waren mega schlecht in dieser Liga, wo halt richtig viele gute Leute drin waren.
Und die waren glaube ich so schlecht, dass die die ersten Games nicht mal einen Turm kaputt gekriegt haben.
Genau, das war das Team mit den Support-Spielern, richtig.
Das darf man, man kann LoL so sehr haten, wie man will.
Das war neben CS eine der so mit Wegbereiter der Sache.
LoL ist Toxic Shit, jedes Multiplayer-Spiel mit PvP ist Toxic Shit.
Guckt ihr auf, ob es ranked an, viel schlimmer kann es auch nicht kommen.
Die meisten Mädels haben sich einfach nicht dafür interessiert.
So lange die nicht auf die Idee kommen, da jetzt auch irgendeine Quote einzuführen oder so.
Naja gut, das ist ja auch mehr Werbegeck für den Sponsor.
Eigentlich ist es genau das Entgegengesetzte, was viele Mädels erreichen wollen.
So nach dem Motto, sie werden nur eingestellt, nicht weil sie gut spielen, sondern weil es ein guter Werbedeal ist.
Ach genau, so hieß die, ich kann mich wieder dran erinnern.
Genau, es hat keiner gekauft und daraufhin haben sie sich den Female Team geholt, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die Entscheidung würde eine Dynamik kreieren, die bis jetzt noch nie existiert hätte.
Für das erste Mal, würde ein Team, vollkommen aus Frauen, in einem Wettbewerb, offiziell organisiert werden.
Das bedeutet, dass es, egal wie unwahrscheinlich es sein würde, eine statistische Chance gab, dass ein Team aus Frauen es in die Welt machen könnte.
Okay, das war theoretisch, theoretisch ist die Chance da, aber dazu hätten sie was gewinnen müssen.
Genau, die Gegner haben Supports gebannt, war das nicht das, wo sogar ein Team Verwarnung bekommen hat?
War das nicht sogar das, wo ein Team eine Verwarnung bekommen hat, weil sie die Charaktere der Gegner gebannt haben oder sowas?
Das war doch was, das war schon ein paar Jahre her, ich kann mich da dunkel dran erinnern.
Ja, haben wir gesagt.
Ah, Kokomorat.
52, sind das die Kills? 52 zu 2? Ach du Scheiße, so viele Kills haben die meisten Games nicht, oder?
Wie viele Kills haben die meisten Games? 20? 20, 25 vielleicht?
Ich kenne mich nur ganz am Rande aus mit LoL, aber die haben halt mega auf den Sack gekriegt.
Oder nee, gut, in dem Fall auf den Sack kann man da nicht sagen, aber sprichwörtlich kann man das sagen.
Für diejenigen, die nicht komplett LoL-savage sind, ist ein Score von 52 zu 2 schrecklich.
Was im Prinzip für den Sponsor das Beste ist, was ihm passieren konnte.
Letztendlich wollen die ja da gewisse Aufmerksamkeit rauskriegen und wenn das funktioniert, ohne dass sie gewinnen,
für den Sponsor ist das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Moment, dazu gibt es ein Rekord?
Warum gibt es denn Rekord dafür? Das ist ein Rekord, das ist ein Negativrekord.
Die hätten den anderen den Rekord geben sollen für fastest win, aber doch nicht fastest loss.
Um das Rekord weiter in die Perspektive zu stellen, möchte ich Sie fragen, ob Sie auf die Social Media folgen,
weil alle Teams Twitter oder Instagram am Ende des Spiels eine gewisse Grafik anbieten,
ob sie gewonnen oder verloren sind.
Oftmals zeigen sie den besten Spieler der Nacht auf einen Sieg und dann auf der Rückseite,
dass sie auf einem Post anbieten, dass sie einen Loss haben.
Und wie vorhin haben es auch E-Sport-Teams dieses Trends genommen.
Und die Victus-Gaming waren kein Schauspieler.
Sie posteten ein Total von 11 Back-to-Back-Grafiken, die alle anbieten, dass sie verloren haben.
Es nahm 11 Spiele in eine Reihe für jemanden, der ihre Instagram-Account anbieten wollte, um zu entscheiden, dass...
Das ist vielleicht keine so gute Idee.
Und es war wirklich nicht.
Das Team endete ihre kompetitive Karriere auf einer historischen 28 Matches.
Sie haben auch in einem Mittelsprungstournament teilgenommen.
Dort spielten sie 6 Spiele und haben sie alle verloren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie dadurch reich geworden sind.
Sie endeten eigentlich auf einer 34 Match Loss-Streak.
Und übrigens, das ist der magische Nummer.
34.
Es nahm in Russland 34 Spiele, um Victus-Gaming offiziell aus dem LCL auszuweichen.
Jetzt denken Sie, dass das ein kompletter Schuss für die Victus-Organisation war.
Ich glaube, das war das Beste für die, was passieren konnte. Ich meine, die wollten aussteigen, die wollten ihre Sache verkaufen.
Keiner wollte sie kaufen.
Und sie haben so viel Aufmerksamkeit dadurch bekommen.
Ich glaube, das war das Beste, was ihnen passieren konnte.
Ja.
Kann mir einer erklären, was Simping ist?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet.
Was ist Simping?
Pfortzenknecht?
Was?
Okay.
Also sprich.
Also, okay, dann versuche ich das mal mit meinen Worten zu umschreiben.
Und ihr sagt mir, ob ich, ob ich Recht habe.
Jemand, der quasi ohne ersichtlichen Grund, also und auch ohne, dass es irgendwie stimmen würde, bei Mädels schleimt den ganzen Tag.
Also beispielsweise das LoL-Team ist schlecht und irgendjemand, der halt übelst abschleimt, rumschleimt, obwohl es nichts zu schleimen gibt.
Okay, ja.
Wenn du von einem Girl das OBS einrichtest und dir mehr erhoffst.
Ah, verstehe.
Ah, aha.
Ja, wie?
Ist OBS einrichten jetzt nicht der neueste Shit?
Also.
Also ich dachte immer, das macht dich ultra attraktiv für Grills, wenn du OBS einrichten kannst.
Das ist etwa nicht so.
Ah.
Ich hätte schon gedacht, ich könnte ein bisschen punkten dadurch, dass ich OBS.
Ich kann sogar Streamlabs OBS einrichten, nicht nur OBS.
Streamlabs OBS, OBS und Donation, Donation Accounts kann ich auch einrichten.
Optional kannst du auch jeden Monat die Monatsmiete im Stream donaten.
Doch, doch, klar habe ich das schon gehört, aber ich konnte mir da nichts darunter vorstellen.
Ich habe doch gerade selbst gesagt, das hörst du an jeder Ecke.
Aber ich habe mich noch nie großartig gefühlt.
Mir war auch klar, dass es irgendwas in Richtung bei Mädels-Rum-Schleim sein muss.
Aber ich habe mir da nie so Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Also gut, im Prinzip ist es einfach ein Schleimer, könnte man sagen.
Das war's für heute.
Das ist dort, wie bei allen anderen E-Sports, Sports, sonst was, gerade in E-Sports Sachen auch.
Wenn sich mal ein paar Mädels finden, die auch den Crime starten und das Spiel quasi, jetzt nicht unbedingt LOL,
irgendwelche anderen Games haben, es kommt ein neues Competitive, gut spielbares Competitive Game raus.
Du hast ein paar Mädels, die sich da hinsetzen und das Spiel 24-7 für ein halbes Jahr grinden,
dann werden die auch ganz gut sein.
Und wenn man mal in Richtung Overwatch guckt, genau, das wollte ich nämlich, Fergsy wollte es gerade sagen,
gerade im Overwatch-Bereich gibt es ja ein paar Mädels.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es, wie hieß die, Griguri, Giguri oder so noch gibt,
wobei ich da halt auch den Eindruck hatte, also wenn man sich den Stream von ihr angeguckt hat,
das war ja früher SariaMain, die ist echt gut, die spielt wirklich gut,
wobei ich da den Eindruck hatte, dass die in dem China-Team drin war und drin bleiben durfte,
war halt auch so ein bisschen Werbegag letztendlich.
Aber die spielt echt gut, muss man sagen.
Es gibt ein paar Mädels bei StarCraft, also ein Mädel bei StarCraft,
aber ich will jetzt da nicht die Diskussion drüber anstoßen.
Offiziell ist sie eine Frau und sie ist richtig gut.
Und ansonsten fallen mir nicht viele Mädels ein.
Im Schach-Bereich gibt es, glaube ich, einige, die richtig gut sind,
aber Schach würde ich jetzt immer nicht so als klassischen E-Sport zählen.
Ansonsten fällt mir da jetzt nicht viel ein,
wo es wirklich Tier-1-Teams gibt mit Mädels.
Keine Ahnung, fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts ein.
Wir reden jetzt ja natürlich was, wo das nicht eh schon getrennt ist.
Also von Sportarten, wo quasi Männer und Frauen getrennt sind,
da ist ja der Vergleich im Prinzip sinnlos.
Da gibt es natürlich jede Menge Tier-1-Teams,
aber wir reden jetzt ja von E-Sport und da fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Ich kenne das Team nicht, aber die war wahrscheinlich einfach gut
und die hat das Game wahrscheinlich auch 24-7 für Monate, wenn nicht Jahre gegrindet.
Okay, das kam jetzt unberechnet, unvorbereitet.
Loll.
Sagen wir mal hier, warum du keine Snickers kaufen solltest.
Okay Leute, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Slowmo, Virus, Snickers, das neue, das kenne ich schon, das ist nicht so gut.
CoD-Campaign, 30 Minuten, Snow, Registry Keys, irgendwelche fahrinformatiger Dinger.
Okay, wir gucken Virus.
Ist das so? Der hat ein paar ganz gute Videos.
Ah, yes.
Ich sehe Leiser.
Das ist ja ein Oldschool Lüfter.
Was ist das? Was ist das für eine Mainboard? Das Mainboard sieht aus wie von 2005.
Schau ich mal das Mainboard an. Das sieht ja Oldschool aus.
Und das Case sieht auch crap aus.
Außerdem, wo sind die RGBs?
Das einzige, was mir jedes Mal auf den Kicks geht, bei einem Windows Setup, ist das Wecklicken von den Datenschutz-Dingern am Anfang.
Wollen sie Anonyme Statistiken? Nein. Wollen sie Location Tracking? Nein.
Wollen sie Cookies? Nein. Wollen sie das? Nein. Wollen sie das? Nein.
Jedes Mal, das sind irgendwie 15 Fragen oder so.
Ne, Cortana ist nicht mehr am Start. Cortana haben sie abgeschafft beim Start.
Cortana war nervig, ja.
Na ja, irgendwelche DOS-Batch-Dinger gehen immer noch.
Wie?
Wie geht denn das, dass man auf so modernen PC nicht Duke Nukem 3D laufen lassen kann?
Das funktioniert gut, aber man hätte erwartet, dass es ein Spiel ist, das auf eine 4.8.6 runnt. Aber dieses Setup lässt uns nun 16-Bit-Kode ausbreiten. Es ist schön von Microsoft, eine Rückwärts-Kompatibilität irgendwo in die Hand zu lassen.
Warum sammelt man sowas?
Warum sammelt man sowas? Ja, keine Ahnung. Warum nicht? Das ist glaube ich eher die Frage.
So geil!
Ahem, ja.
Moment, das gibt's heute noch?
Ja.
Das ist... Okay, es scheint wirklich einige Archive zu geben davon.
Okay.
Geht das überhaupt, wenn man den aktuellen Windows Defender anhat? Der wird das doch alles erkennen.
Ja.
Windows Defender, warum null? Das ist die beste Sache, die ihr installieren könnt für Antivirus. Entweder gar keinen oder Windows Defender. Alles andere ist Blödsinn.
Chat, behaltet ruhig Windows Defender, besser als irgendwie zusätzlichen Crap zu installieren.
Gut, Bootsektor Zugriff hat das Ding schonmal eh nicht unter dem normalen User unter Windows 10.
Cool.
Krasser Hacker-Man.
Das ist ja halt ziemlich Lorpray in Virus. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den SL zu ContaLinux.
Wow.
Das war's für heute.
Hatespeech.
Der Autofokus seiner Kamera macht mich verrückt.
Okay, der löscht nur den Speicher, der überschreibt nicht das BIOS selbst, weil das wäre echt Fail.
ExpressVPN.
Der Lautstärke-Unterschied dürfte doch gar nicht so groß sein, oder?
Oder? Ein bisschen.
Max, streamst du den ganzen Nachmittag durch? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich finde irgendwie, das war voll kreativ noch, das ganze Virus Zeug.
Zwar nicht, wir verschlüsseln deine Festplatte und über Weißbitcoins.
Die haben sich ja noch richtig Mühe gegeben.
Also, ich würde es auf jeden Fall niemals auf meinem Host ausführen.
Ich bin auch nicht mit DOSBox, sondern immer in der FM.
No Happy Meal for you, 12 Monate Poggers.
Exzellent Subscription.
Das wird in 2020, lul.
Der soll jetzt einfach alle Viren aufführen, auf einmal, hintereinander.
Exzellent. Exzellent.
Da sagt es, hab das gehört.
Okay, der führt jetzt wirklich alle 60.000 aus.
Okay, PowerShell hat sich bereits damit beschäftigt.
Also, ich werde ein paar Virussen manuell öffnen, nur um die Leidenschaften zu geben.
Nach nicht langer Zeit war es eindeutig, dass Seriöse Probleme setzten.
Alle COM-File hatten schon seit ein paar Jahren ihre originelle Größe, wahrscheinlich,
als sie weitergekommen wurden, infektiert durch das Malware.
Das hatte auch Probleme für Windows PowerShell.
Und es begann zu haben, Probleme mit dem Öffnen von etwas.
Nicht zu erwähnen, dass es nun eine COM-File war, die Hundert.com in der Direktur war.
Aber es war viel schlimmer, außerhalb davon.
Oh Mann, schau dir das an! Ich kann es nicht...
Was ist hier los? Schau dir das an!
Es ist absolut verabschiedet!
Das sind deine definitiven Antworten!
Was ist das?
Das ist eine File, die auf dem Desktop steht.
Es gibt auch eine COM-File.
Kann ich sogar mit der Total-AV laufen?
Wird es sogar öffnen?
Schauen wir mal, was passiert.
Ich denke, dass das Computer offiziell kaputt geworden ist.
Das ist kein Indikative eines sehr heiligen Hard Drives.
Ich kann nicht sogar eine Highlight-Box machen.
Es bleibt einfach im Hintergrund.
Das ist total verabschiedet.
Oh Mann!
Okay, also das Wichtigste ist, dass das DOS-Ära-Malware in der Wahrheit
Karnage in den Fenstern der Windows-Digital-Redditschriften verursacht werden kann.
Auch jetzt, also es ist dein Bestes, es zu verhindern.
Ernsthaft, bitte nicht.
Okay, an diesem Punkt möchte ich Total-AV-Antivirus danken.
Okay, jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen Sellout.
Ich muss mir jetzt ein bisschen Lego angucken.
Exzellent.
Lego Schnee.
Was ist das?
Was ist denn ein Snowplow-Train?
Schnee-Gebläse, also immer.
Schneeräumen, Schneeräumen, Schneeflug.
Ich glaube, da ist so der Lego-Motor nicht das Richtige für die Musik.
Was ist das?
BTF, was ist das für Musik?
BTF, was ist das für Grabmusik, Alter?
3-Heads.
Oh, jetzt kommt der Big Brain-Move.
Warum dampft das da oben?
Moment, es kann hupen.
Die Musik, die macht mich fertig.
Es funktioniert.
So, und damit jetzt, damit darf er jetzt den ganzen Hof sauber machen.
Dann lieber Ayaya-Step.
Was auch immer.
Ist das aus dem PC, was?
Der Windows ist abgekackt.
Das ist langweilig.
Das ist bestimmt auch langweilig, das ist bestimmt auch langweilig.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt Slow-Motion an.
Slow-Motion von was?
Von Termite.
Was ist denn Termite auf Deutsch?
Termit.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich mal eine Übersetzung, wo man drauf kommen kann.
Erstmal eine Runde Sellout machen.
Was, nur 1000?
Da geht aber mehr.
Ich hab hier schon 240.
Ah, das gibt's in Battlefield 4 auch, das ist dieses Ding, was man werfen kann.
Dieser Granatenersatz in Battlefield 4.
Und in Dings, in Warzone gibt's das auch.
Außerdem, ich wollte gerade sagen, wie sollen wir 1000 FPS sehen überhaupt, nachdem das menschliche Auge nur 12 kann.
Riptopf.
Ja, JCone12, aber du hast zum Glück zwei Augen, also kommst du auf 24.
Das sieht nice aus.
Drei.
Ja, wenn du drei Augen hast, dann siehst du, nee, nee, nee, nee, das geht plus bis zwei, da ist Cap.
Bei 24 FPS ist Cap, egal wie viele Augen.
Hard Cap.
Er hat irgendwie schon so ein bisschen Hypnotische Wirkung, ne?
Sieht aus wie ein Vulkan-Ausbruch.
Schwer für Wafferegen, genau.
Ist der F-16 nicht ein Flugzeug?
Also entweder dehnt sich das jetzt so weit aus, dass das Glasding platzt, glaube ich aber nicht.
Wahrscheinlich wirst du einfach Blasen sehen, ne?
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Ja, Blasen.
Matze 2090, drei Monate, dankeschön, exzellent.
Da kommt man mal nach, Monate, jetzt geht's aber ab hier.
Ah, yes.
Casey86, Twitch Brian, dankeschön.
Oh, der Scamtrain ist unterwegs, Leute.
Der Scamtrain läuft.
Wie viele Abos haben die eigentlich?
Boah, 14 Millionen, fuck, Alter.
Ich wusste, dass die groß sind, aber nicht, dass die so groß sind.
Weil die machen ja seit Jahren im Prinzip genau das, Slow-Motion von irgendwelchen Dingern.
Hättest du auch, wenn du regelmäßig Videos machst, dann müsste ich aber äußerst regelmäßig
Videos machen und anderen Content vor allem.
Zeug kaputt machen in Slow-Mo, ja.
Cool, Sword, dankeschön, oh, BitConnect.
Dankeschön, zwei Monate.
So.
Und was ist jetzt der Unterschied zu vorher?
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Wieso haben wir manche Amounts doppelt?
Haben wir die?
Welche haben wir denn doppelt?
Ey, es sieht schon irgendwie cool aus, ja.
Zwar komplett sinnlos, aber es ist cool.
Okay, Odi, Twitch Prime, dankeschön, Subscription, huge.
Okay, Champ.
Haben wir nicht, haben wir nicht Okay Champ schon aktiviert?
Wir haben einen Weird Champ.
Ich glaub, Okay Champ haben wir nicht.
Wir haben keinen Okay Champ, das füge ich gleich mal hinzu.
Okay Champ.
Moment, gleich haben wir Okay Champ.
So, Okay Champ ist geadded.
Aber das dauert kurz.
Yep, yep, füge ich nicht hinzu.
Yep, darf nur ich benutzen hier.
Nee, Pog, Pog, Pog-O ist richtig dumm.
Warum wollt ihr Pog-O verwenden?
Okay, chat, jetzt hab ich mal ne Frage.
An welcher Stelle verwendet man Pog-O?
Wann ist, welche Situation muss sein, dass man Pog-O verwendet?
Wenn ihr mir das, dann füge ichs hinzu.
Das ist das neue Yep ein.
Pog-O ist Weird Champ Ersatz.
Okay, Pog-O.
Emote.
Okay, ich hab's hinzugefügt.
Ich hab's hinzugefügt.
Aber wie gesagt, dauert immer kurz und außerdem muss man Chat refreshen.
Dass es funktioniert.
Wie oft will er das jetzt noch machen?
Oh, der ganze Eimer fackelt hier ab.
Warum können nicht Emojis doch Twitch-Emotes ersetzt werden?
Ja, das frag ich mich auch.
Okay, ich erkenne jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel.
Außer dass es ein bisschen aussieht wie an Sylvester.
Okay, das machen die halt schon eine Weile und das kommt gut an.
Die haben bestimmt bessere Videos in der Richtung.
Das fand ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig spannend.
Warum du kein Snickers kaufen solltest, haben wir ja noch.
Warum denn?
Warum soll man kein Snickers kaufen?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt erklären lassen.
Bestimmt weil Kinderarbeit oder so.
Echt?
Flamehaze.
Null.
Irgendwie dachte ichs mir schon.
unternehmen mars incorporated die welt mit snickers und von beginn an waren
vermutlich kinder an der herstellung beteiligt nicht als testesser sondern
als arbeitsglaven auf einer der unzähligen kakao plantagen in westafrika
anfang der 2000 gab es das erste mal solche vorwürfe eine investigativ
dokumentation der bbc da ist aber snickers nicht das einzige es macht es
nicht besser machte damals die ganze welt auf das riesige problem aufmerksam
die journalisten interviewten malavische kinder sklaven diese waren an kakao
plantagen in der elfenbeinküste verkauft worden
there's nothing to stop these young men leaving the plantation except that
they've been trafficked 300 miles from home they're penniless and they have no
idea where they are paid nothing unable to leave and totally
controlled by the farmer neben mars standen auch schokoladen produzenten
wie hershey und nestle in der kritik sie alle räumten ein dass in der
vergangenheit einiges schief gelaufen sei jetzt wolle man die kinderarbeit auf
kakao plantagen aber bekämpfen mittlerweile sind fast kannst du das
video machen warum man kein apple samsung kaufen sollte ja mal gucken
können wir uns auch angucken und naja es hat sich so gut wie nichts getan
warum auch die leute kaufen den kram und so lange die leute den kram kaufen warum
sollten sie was ändern ich meine die das ist ja die beste
situation für so einen hersteller rein aus mannysicht quasi die sache ist an die
öffentlichkeit gekommen es ist bekannt es interessiert keine sau also mannimanni
stammt der schokoladenindustrie haben das massive problem immer noch nicht in den
griff bekommen die wollen gar nicht von kindern schuften auch im jahr 2020 die
wollen nicht unter wie gesagt das das beste was ihnen passieren kann ist die
leute wissen den leuten ist es egal sie kaufen den scheiß weiterhin weil das
einzige was dazu führen könnte dass sie das anders machen ist dass die leute
nicht mehr kaufen oder aber da kommen mal irgendwelche leute mit also nicht
stonks leute sondern leute mit irgendwie noch ein bisschen einfühlvermögen ran
aber das ist ja da nicht gewollt ja amt watt ist neu hier
alles heißt am 2d wahrscheinlich bedingungen auf den plantagen sie
müssen kakaofrüchte mit macheten vom baum schlagen und wohnen in der hitze zum
trocknen auf bananen blättern auslegen sie müssen schwere säcke schleppen und
ungeschützt giftige pesticide versprühen keines der großen schokoladen
unternehmen kann garantieren dass ihre schokolade frei von kinderarbeit ist viele
wissen teils nicht einmal von welchen farmen ihre kakao hast du dir im stream
auch mal temple us angeschaut nee wie kann das sein wie kann man so versagt
es interessiert einfach kein die haben aus ihrer sicht haben die wahrscheinlich
nicht versagt aus ihrer sicht denken sie ok so lange die leute den scheiß kaufen
warum sollen was ändern als würde das irgendwie als würde jetzt auch nur
ansatzweise interessieren dass dort kinder auf der kakao plantage arbeiten
das den noch vollkommen egal das ist genauso wie die leute bei kick nicht
juckt dass das irgendein kanon bangladesch irgendwelche kinder genäht
haben oder irgendwelche elektronikteile unter unmenschlichen bedingungen in
china und nordkorea produziert wenn man sonst was juckt die leute einfach nicht
und solange sie leute nicht juckt und sie den kram nicht kaufen wird es auch
die hersteller wenig jucken weil da hat doch keiner irgendwie ein schlechtes
gewissen was das angeht für schokolade braucht man kakaobohnen die stammen
größtenteils aus westafrika insbesondere aus der elfenbeinküste und
gana dort arbeiten kinder weil sie billige arbeitskräfte sind und die
bauern sich keine erwachsenen leisten können bei einigen kinder arbeitern
haben menschenhändler ihre finger im spiel das benachbarte boquina faso ist
noch ärmer als gana und die elfenbeinküste kinder vertrauen sich dort
oft skrupellosen schleppern an in der hoffnung auf ein besseres leben dann
werden sie aber versklavt und an ivorische kakao plantagen verkauft die
allermeisten kinder sind jedoch in familienbetrieben tätig schulen sind
oft zu teuer oder es gibt keine ihre einzige perspektive ist die arbeit
familienbetrieb kann man das auch nennen auf der familienplantage es wird
immer mehr kakao angebaut und nachgefragt dementsprechend ist die
anzahl der kinder arbeiter ebenfalls gestiegen zwischen 2009 und 2014 sind
über 440.000 kinder dazugekommen insgesamt sind mittlerweile über zwei
millionen kinder auf ivorischen und ganaschen plantagen tätig das gigantische
problem näher die werden sich wahrscheinlich denken so doofs klingt gibt
halt genug kindernachschub und so lange es nicht sich finanziell bei denen
irgendwie auswirkt wird da wahrscheinlich niemals jemand was dran
ändern es sei denn die bedingungen drumherum ändern sich die gesamte
schokoladenindustrie und ist nur sehr schwer zu lösen das wissen die konzerne
natürlich auch es gibt nicht die eine oder die zwei gigantischen plantagen
die man einfach dicht machen könnte tatsächlich sind es knapp zwei
millionen äußerst kleine betriebe der weg des kakaos von dort in die
maßfabriken in europa und den usa ist lang und undurchsichtig also
wortwörtlich oft gibt es keine straßen und man kann die plantagen nur über
lange fußwege erreichen
der kampf gegen mich würde sogar mal interessieren ob mal angenommen dort
gibt es irgendwie eine plantage die eltern sind am start und irgendwie keine
ahnung zehn kinder kommt ja öfters mal vor dass man mehr kinder hat was die
leute dazu sagen wenn das die einzige möglichkeit ist da irgendwie geld zu
verdienen wohl gemerkt hat natürlich werden sie ausgebeutet mich würde mal
interessieren was die leute selbst dazu sagen
also sprich
sind wenn du dort kinder auf so einer plantage fragen würdest ob sie da quasi
so art quasi so art arbeitsklaven sind was sie dazu sagen würden weil vielleicht
vielleicht sagen da auch einige dazu das ist die einzige möglichkeit geld zu
verdienen wie wir hier über die runden kommen natürlich ist es nicht macht es
nicht besser vor allem wenn du dir überlegst dass die wahrscheinlich 0,01
prozent von dem gesamten produkt abbekommen im endeffekt an kohle ist
gleichzeitig ein kampf gegen armut die langfristige lösung für das problem
klingt relativ simpel die bauern müssen fair vergütet werden
ja ok ok das ist natürlich ein schenkel klopfer aber dann könnten viele ihre
kinder zur schule schicken und sich erwachsene arbeiter leisten doch trotz
zertifikaten trotz massiver berichterstattung und trotz verboten
verdienen sie immer noch zu wenig und das daran siehst du es juckt halt
letztendlich keinen und dementsprechend stellt er auch keiner
irgendwie sein kaufverhalten um weltweit von jahr zu jahr immer mehr leute
schokolade essen sie haben keine lobby und bei preisverhandlungen so gut wie
keine macht wenn sie mehr geld verlangen findet man millionen andere
bauern die den niedrigen preis akzeptieren jedes land der welt hat die
un kinderrechtskonvention von 1989 unterschrieben also bis auf die
kinder sollen vor aus hell ja und haben ein recht auf bildung eigentlich sind
natürlich jeweils die regierungen der einzelnen länder für die einhaltung
dieser kinderrechte verantwortlich die elfenbeinküste ist aber zum beispiel kaum
in der lage sich davon abgesehen dass es ja auch das papier nicht wert auf dem
steht kümmern das land ist arm korrupt und in den vergangenen 20 jahren gab es
zwei bürgerkriege ok kurzes quiz wie viel geld steht der
ivorischen spezialeinheit für die bekämpfung von menschenhandel und
kinderarbeit jährlich zur verfügung naja so viel haben die wahrscheinlich im
ganzen jahr nicht dann müssen es wahrscheinlich 5000 sein so so viel geld
haben die nicht wo sollen die so viel geld haben das können höchstens 5000
sein also 5 millionen wäre schon echt 5.000 dollar 5.000
als reaktion auf die massive berichterstattung wurden 2001 strengere
gesetze für die globalen schokoladen produzenten gefordert in den usa gab es
bereits einen gesetzesentwurf für ein industrieweites label dagegen haben die
hersteller aber erfolgreich lobbyarbeit betrieben als kompromiss wurde 2001 das
haken da gibt es die ersten jetzt schon wieder drüber meckern würden
wahrscheinlich das weil die schwarze hände sind und weiß in dem fall halt
echt passt schokolade und es geht um afrika also und eins das haken engel
protocol unterzeichnet eine vereinbarung zwischen regierungen der
globalen schokoladenindustrie und einigen NGOs es verpflichtete mars
nestle herrschi und einige weitere hersteller gegen kinderarbeit auf
kakaoplantagen vorzugehen die umsetzung war aber genau wie die unterzeichnung des
plans das ist so ein ding ja wir unterscheiden
wissen da saßen jetzt irgendwie wie viel sind das
ja wie viel haben da unterschrieben 1 2 3 4 7 da saßen jetzt irgendwie acht
ceos im fünfsterne restaurant oder auf der insel im fünfsterne puff keine
ahnung und haben sich gegenseitig die hände
geschüttelt und gesagt war ein zukunftsrechtiges abkommen und als sie
da rausgegangen sind haben sich gedacht ja hookers nestle herrschi und einige
weitere hersteller gegen kinderarbeit auf kakaoplantagen vorzugehen
das ist so ein ding das ist auch wieder das papier nicht wert worauf steht
setzung war aber genau wie die unterzeichnung des plans freiwillig und
wer hätte es gedacht bis heute wurden wichtige teile des plans nicht erfüllt
deadlines wurden immer wieder verfehlt oder um mehrere jahre verschoben auch
wenn mars nestle herrschi und co gerne so tun als ob in der vergangenheit
ist wie mit unseren kohlekraftwerken sind wir mal 2038 jetzt in heit haben sie
keine verantwortung übernommen auf das neue ziel für 2020 wird aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach wieder nichts als teil des plans sollte 2005 auch ein
industrieweites siegel eingeführt werden das hat bis heute noch nicht
geklappt stattdessen stellen freiwillig machen wir das ja auch nicht warum soll
die sich freiwillig auf ihre packung was drauf drucken das ist so wie wenn sich
die zigaretten hersteller freiwillig diese bildchen drauf drucken würden
warum soll die freiwillig auf ihre packungen drucken diese schokolade
wird in kinderarbeit hergestellt andere organisationen zertifikate für kakao aus
sie garantieren zumindest dass bauern besser vergütet werden und investieren
in kampagnen gegen kinderarbeit mittlerweile gibt es wahnsinnig viele
dieser anbieter die miteinander konkurrieren sie bieten zertifizierte
kakaobohnen zu unterschiedlichen preisen an schokoladen produzenten greifen immer
häufiger zu den günstigsten der großteil der von fairtrade zertifizierten
bauernfamilien in der elfenbeinküste lebte 2018 immer noch unter der absoluten
armutsgrenze und das trotz garantierte mindestpreis und festgelegter prämie
der führende zertifikatsanbieter die rainforest alliance zahlt den bauern
zwar auch mehr geld als üblich es gibt aber keinen mindestpreis bauern sind
vor fallenden kakaopreisen also gar nicht geschützt
wenn überall so ein siegel drauf ist aber gleichzeitig das siegel nicht
sicherstellen kann dass keine kinder arbeiten was bedeutet es denn
letztendlich zertifikate sind also keine 100 was es bedeutet ganz einfach die
hersteller können was draufdrucken und freuen sich das ist ein bisschen wie
ihr wisst ja ich arbeite im finanzsektor aber in der it ich habe
damit ja nichts zu tun dort ist es gang und gäbe dass sich
irgendwelche siegel drauf gepappt werden die im zweifelsfall zweifelsfall wurden
die selbst ausgestellt vollkommen egal da klebt auch auf allem irgendein komisches
wichtig zu siegel drauf so nach dem motto sieger 2020 und blau und sonst wie
dass das ist das papier auch nicht wert worauf steht garantie dass schokolade
frei von kinderarbeit ist sie sind aber definitiv besser als keine
zertifikate das klingt logisch wir haben fünf der
größten schokoladen produzenten kontaktiert unsere fragen bezüglich des
haken engel protokolls wurden ignoriert ein einheitliches was auch sonst wird
anscheinend auch nicht befürwortet alle unternehmen betonen dass systeme
entwickelt wurden durch die gefährdete kinder auf farmen identifiziert natürlich
geschützt natürlich darüber hinaus wollen dann soll sie mal erklären wie
sie das machen wollen produzenten in den nächsten fünf
jahren nur noch zertifizierte kakaobohne nutzen tun es schon oder wollen ihre
eigenen standards weiter ausbauen all diese initiativen der industrie wirken
vielversprechend und proaktiv aber reichen sie aus die die dinger diese
sachen sind einfach nur da dass man auf angenehme dass man auf unangenehme
rückfragen sagen kann man macht da was man will ja da gar nichts machen
reichen sie aus das brainwashing das ist einfach sich gut selber ein gutes
gewissen machen ja autor und kinderrecht aktivist würde mich jetzt auch nicht
wundern beschäftigt sich seit das ist ein bisschen so wie die ganzen
unternehmen dieser jahren quasi umweltverschmutzen oder für
verbrennungs sachen werden jetzt auf einmal bäume pflanzen und und tolle programme
haben für windkraft und wir waren schon immer wahnsinnig grün und sonst was
auch kompletter blödsinn einfach das ist einfach nur um sich hinzustellen und
sagen zu können wir sind ja ganz toll 30 jahren mit kinderarbeit auf der ganzen
welt wirklich ist nicht freiwilligkeit wirklich ist nicht eigenkontrollen
wirklich ist nur unabhängig kontrollen von außen pütter fordert deshalb seit
jahrzehnten ein lieferketten gesetz das könnte dazu beitragen dass
menschenrechte in der gesamten lieferkette und damit auch im ausland
geschützt werden müssen dass es dringend regulierung braucht sehen
mittlerweile auch einige der großen schokoladenhersteller ein wir als
konsumenten müssen jetzt aber nicht auf schokolade also also ich ich hätte eine
idee was man dagegen machen könnte so so der kokona way wäre wir könnten
einfach waffen an die an die kinder auf den plantagen exportieren und wir wissen
ja sobald man waffen hat jetzt alles besser was dann da ansonsten rechts kann
es auch egal sein und wir sind ja gut da drin was waffen exportieren angeht und
ich meine wer braucht nicht eine eigene ak 74 oder na gut wir sind ja keine
russen wer braucht nicht g 36 ein eigenes das ist doch logisch oder verzichten
oder so das würde millionen von bauern die
lebensgrundlage rauben wir können unternehmen mit unserer kaufentscheidung
aber dazu zwingen auf zertifizierte kakaobohnen zu setzen eventuell zahlen
wir dann etwas mehr für unsere schokoriegel yo max was sagst du zum
angel camp ich habe da am anfang schon was zu gesagt ich persönlich kann die
begeisterung nicht so ganz nachvollziehen wirkt auf mich im prinzip
wie rtl auf twitch wem es gefällt schön es ist aktuell die beste option für uns
auch wenn das wie gesagt leider immer noch nicht garantiert dass die
schokolade frei von kinderarbeit ist auf der einen seite das knickers für einen
euro von der tankstelle auf der anderen ein moment bei der tankstelle kostet
350 mit ein euro in der elfenbeinküste dazwischen findet man wahnsinnig viel
ungerechtigkeit und scheinheilige unternehmen die davon profitieren
sie versuchen mit aller macht sich vor der verantwortung für das leid von
millionen von kindern zu drücken bisher leider mit erfolg wenn dein kumpel das
nächste mal zur diva wird überzeugen doch einfach von einer zertifizierten
variante und der hungar ist gegessen
hey hoffentlich hat euch das video gefallen schreibt uns eure meinung zu
dem thema unbedingt in die kommentare eine woche vollzeit streamer und
verdienen wer will schon vollzeit streamer werden so
lang bin ich da schon alle fast drei stunden was sollte ich noch gucken warum
man warum kein samsung kaufen solltest oder wie keine ahnung
schau dir mal urban dictionary an kennisch das gott wieder zum abschluss
okay gibt es irgendwas anderes ein mittel gegen unzufriedenheit
kurz gesagt ist auch immer nice kommt so an unzufrieden alle sind
unzufrieden es sind nicht alle nur zufrieden es sind alle da noch dabei der
restlichen welt mitzuteilen wie unzufrieden sie sind mit allem alle
unzufrieden und dann auf twitter gehen erst mal sich schön empören und sich
aufregen
ich habe hunger wir gucken jetzt noch jeder kurz gesagt die machen immer gute
videos big brain videos barbecue pit boys
hell yeah erst mal das hier wenn sich einfach nichts richtig an
pp hans
die beziehung nicht glücklich genug und das hätte man einfach nicht das
wonach man sich sehnt welche beziehung eine chronische unzufriedenheit die uns
mit neid auf andere blicken lässt und mit enttäuschung auf uns selbst pop
kultur werbung und soziale medien machen es noch schlimmer laut ihnen muss nicht
ein job zu 100 prozent erfüllen du musst ständig großartige erfahrungen
dem schönheitsideal entsprechen einen haufen freunde haben und deinen seelen
verwandten finden scheinbar muss man muss man nicht wirklich also man kann
auch einfach auf twitch den livestream anmachen und poggers emotes bem und alle
anderen genauso ein leben und sind total glücklich und natürlich sorgt der
selbstoptimierungstrend dafür dass du dich so fühlst als müsstest du nur hart
genug an dir arbeiten um das alles auch zu erreichen
ja vor 20 jahren haben wissenschaftler mit der suche nach einem gegenmittel für
das ist ja so ein bisschen was was ich auch schon seit anfang also was ich was
ich schon in vielen youtube videos kritisiert habe dass es so viele videos
gibt so nach dem motto also diese komplett unrealistische dinger erzählen
so nach dem motto ja guckt das an ich habe das geschafft und ihr könnt das
auch schaffen ihr müsst nur daran glauben und es ist ganz einfach
die meisten das ist nicht einfach je nachdem was man haben will und viele
leute haben träume die sie nie erreichen werden ich weil man sollte auch mal der
realität ins auge ins auge schauen ja also wenn ich jetzt keine ich bin jetzt
36 fast so und wenn ich jetzt sagt keine ahnung ich möchte mal
kein was total bescheuert also ich möchte mal 100 meter weltrekord laufen
das ist schwachsinn ja man muss man muss schon gucken dass das ganze irgendwo
realistisch ist und ja die sachen sind so voll wie soll man das beschreiben so
so ist irgendwie so philosophie leid irgendwie so nach dem motto ja glaub an
dich und du kannst alles schaffen ja super am besten kommst du noch in die
telegram oder in die whatsapp gruppe
ja
wichtig und das ist das war ihr leute ich bin jetzt 35 ich bin ich habe jetzt ich
habe jetzt schon ein paar jahre hinter mir als komm kommen hoffentlich noch ein
paar das wichtigste und was viele leute glaube ich zumindest noch nicht auf die
reine gekriegt haben was auch ein bisschen was auch ein bisschen braucht
viele sagen dass sie das so denken glauben denken es aber nicht wirklich ist
dass man richtig boomer richtig boomer genau ist erstens dass man weniger drauf
gibt am besten gar nichts wie andere das finden was man macht und das geht nur
weil man irgendwie mit sich selbst halbwegs zufrieden ist oder oder sich
zumindest so akzeptiert wie man ist das dauert das dauert ja man denkt immer
man muss irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen rum rum doktorn irgendwas machen weil
man weiß ja nicht wie das ganze ankommt und was irgendwelche leute drüber denken
und wie kann das sein dass man das nicht mag obwohl es doch 90 prozent der leute
auch mögen doch kann sein ist überhaupt kein problem ich habe zum
beispiel früher immer gedacht ich bin nicht normal weil also an viel vielen
sachen zum beispiel zum beispiel ich hatte immer den eindruck es gehen alle
voll gerne auf die weihnachtsfeier auf der arbeit so als beispiel letzt mal ja
und ich hasse weihnachtsfeiern
ich kann das überhaupt nicht habe ich mag auch keinerlei irgendwelche
sommerfeste events oder andere dinger also ich mag generell soziale aktivitäten
mit leuten die ich nicht unbedingt die ich nicht kenne nicht mag nicht sonst
was mag ich nicht ja so da habe ich da habe ich echt keinen bock drauf und ich
hatte immer den eindruck so nach dem motto das ist doch nicht normal einfach
olli zwei monat dankeschön excellent subscription da ich dachte immer früher
das ist doch nicht normal dass man dass das guck mal auf der arbeit freuen sich
alle immer wenn man mal ehrlich ist nein ist nicht so viele haben da auch kein
bock drauf nur die sagen es dir nicht ja die sagen sie nicht es gibt genug die
das auch kacke finden und mittlerweile habe ich mich damit
abgefunden dass ich so soziale events nicht ab kann und ich sage den leuten
mittlerweile schon das ist nichts für mich liegt nicht an euch aber ich mag so
dinger nicht und die verstehen dass die verstehen dass es ist besser wenn du es
den leuten einfach sagt was sache ist anstatt dass du damit gehst und den
eindruck vermittelst du hast keinen bock auf die leute also am besten ist man
sagt und die meisten leute verstehen das auch wenn du sagst hey wie so große
menschen ansammlung mit vielen leuten das ist nichts für mich da sagen die
leute ok wusste ich nicht dann dann weiß ich ja weshalb du da immer nicht
hingehst vollkommen also es ist bis jetzt noch nicht einmal passiert dass
irgendwie einer mir das ausreden wollte also jetzt ernsthaft ja einfach einfach
sagen wie es ist einfach sagen wie es ist
ja und das ist glaube ich eine sache wo viele wo viele leute eine weile für
brauchen dass sie sich damit abfinden können dass sie halt so sind wie sie
sind ja und es heißt jetzt nicht wenn einem irgendwas total auf den keks geht
an sich selbst ja dass man da nichts ändern kann aber die sache ist halt du
ist halt ist halt die man muss nichts an sich ändern nur weil irgendjemand
anderem das nicht gefällt um ein schlechtes gewissen bekommt so nach dem
motto or das gefällt andere nicht wenn man das selbst so sieht dann ist was
anderes zum beispiel wenn man pippo fett ist ja und man sich selbst sagt ich will
nicht mehr pippo fett sein dann ist ok da kann man sagen ok ich mache jetzt was
dass ich nicht mehr pippo fett bin aber dann ist ja man selbst der antrieb
dahinter
und natürlich kann der auslöser unter anderem sein dass das vielleicht in dass
du blöde kommentare kriegst oder sonst wo aber das sorgt meiner erfahrung nach
blöde kommentare von anderen leuten eher nicht dazu dass man da langfristig in
irgendwas motiviert ist man muss man muss das selbst man muss das selbst wollen und
bei vielen sachen ist halt einfach so es muss einem mit der zeit einfach ziemlich
egal sein was was da aber ist da andere leute
erzählen sonst machst du den ganz ich kenne was
von früher noch du machst dir quasi im prinzip den halben tag gedanken
irgendwie über was was andere leute gesagt haben wo die sich selbst keine
gedanken darüber gemacht haben total bescheuern das ist total total beknackt
man muss sich einfach auch damit abfinden dass die welt voller spasten
ist es gibt also 70 prozent der leute sind
nicht bewusst nicht bewusst aber also es ist jetzt nicht so weil die leute sagen
alter ich möchte jetzt ich möchte in den arsch sein oder so das passt einfach
nicht zu einem selbst ja und ja es gibt es gibt auch leute die die machen
absichtlich auf arsch ja klar aber die meisten leute sind halt so wie sie sind
ich denke mir halt alter was für spasten ja und sind halt 70 prozent der leute
es denken die übrigens das denken die anderen dann auch die denkens warum ist
der max so bescheuert oder warum ist er warum was will er überhaupt ist normal
weiter ist die positive psychologie entstanden sie erforscht was das leben
lebenswert macht außerdem wurde die kognitive verhaltenstherapie entwickelt
um negativen was das leben lebenswert macht ist eigentlich aus meiner sicht
total einfach möglichst viel zeit damit verbringen was einem spaß macht das ist
eigentlich alles
wissenschaftler stellten sich die frage warum sind manche menschen glücklicher
und zufriedener als andere und können wir von dem lernen was sie automatisch
richtig machen in diesem video geht es um eines der
wichtigsten anzeichnungen wie glücklich wir sind wie leicht es uns fällt freunde
zu finden und gar nicht krisen umgehen können sozusagen ich hasse alle
anderen menschen außer den twitch chat nur der twitch ist das einzige was ich
mir geben kann selbst verbesserungstrend klingen der vom hashtag folg gepredigt
wird aber tatsächlich basieren alle erkenntnisse in diesem bereich auf
zahlreichen studien links in der video beschreibung dankbarkeit kann für jeden
menschen und in jeder lebenslage etwas anderes bedeuten sie ist ein charakter
zug ein gefühl eine tugend und eine verhaltensweise man kann sie jemandem
gegenüber empfinden der etwas nettes getan hat aber zum beispiel auch für das
wetter die natur oder eine glückliche fügung und sie ist fest in unseren genen
verankert wie dankbarkeit uns miteinander verbindet vor der dankbarkeit gab es
zunächst das prinzip der gegenseitigkeit eine bei tieren angeborene
motivation dinge zum gegenseitigen ah jetzt dieses verhalten findet man bei manchen fischen
vögeln säugetieren und vor allem bei primaten wenn dein gehirn feststellt dass
jemand etwas nettes für dich getan hat reagiert es mit dankbarkeit und motiviert
dich so dazu dich zu revanchieren dass sie dafür dass wir uns um andere kümmern
und sie sich um uns eine sehr wichtige entwicklung denn als das menschliche
gehirn mit der zeit lernte die gefühle anderer besser zu deuten wurden
egoistische individuen schnell identifiziert das stimmt aber echt das
stimmt das stimmt aber echt manchmal kommt man mit einfach nett sein also
kommt man besser rum als mit leute an kacken zum beispiel fällt mir der
fällt mir eine sache jetzt jetzt direkt ein zum beispiel wir haben auf der
arbeit quasi in den team oder hatten wir das jetzt schon ein bisschen her was
ich um vms kümmert ist jetzt ein prinzip auch egal was die machen und ich
habe mal t online bestellt und da war so eine probe packung dabei und ich bin
mal den mal vorbei gegangen und hab dem einen quasi die probe packung mit
gebracht hab gesagt hier ich hab was für euch weil ihr euch immer so schön um
unsere linux vms kümmert das war war eigentlich nette geste ja ich weiß auch
nicht was mit mir los war also normalerweise würde ich sowas ja nicht
machen ist ja also das ist ja zu viel zu zwischen menschlich zumindest habe ich
das habe ich das dem eingegeben und ihr glaubt das nicht das hat er mir jahrelang
erzählt und er hat sich jedes mal wenn ich dort ein ticket aufgemacht habe oder
irgendwas wollte hat er sich sofort drum gekümmert also man sieht dass man mit
solchen sachen manchmal einfacher irgendwie da was heißt zum ziel zum ziel
wird ja ich hab das irgendwie berechnet oder so habe ich nicht ja dass man
einfacher sachen bekommt man einfach nur nett ist manchmal manchmal als wenn man
nur den ganzen tag die leute anscheißt das ist das das ist das was man so im
großen und ganzen glaube ich als nächsten liebe wenn man da jetzt mal
irgendwie christlich wird zusammen fast oder generell könnte man das glaube ich
so sagen also also eigentlich nicht meine meine stärke so wirklich mit anderen
verschaffte uns also einen evolutionsvorteil hatte ein mensch zum
beispiel hunger und jemand zeigte ihm einen platz mit leckeren bären hatte ihm
gegenüber dankbarkeit empfunden es entstand eine verpflichtung den
gefallen zu erwidern und danach und danach gab es gatschi bass und ganz viele
kleine neuen steinzeit menschen mit einer motivation sich sozial zu
verhalten wurde der gefallen schließlich erwidert empfand das
gegenüber wieder dankbarkeit dieses prinzip hat unsere vorfahren eng
zusammengeschweißt diese frühen formen der dankbarkeit waren biologische
mechanismen die erde zu erobern aber im laufe der zeit ist aus dankbarkeit
und du hast recht motivation für faires handeln
stimmt stimmt falsches falsches ima und ich habe aber ich habe aber dafür keine
andere zima und dankbarkeit wissenschaftlern zufolge regt dankbarkeit
im gehirn zentren für belohnung und soziale bindungen an und verbessert
außerdem unsere fähigkeit die absichten andere zu deuten dankbarkeit wirkt sogar
direkt die haben immer so die haben immer so gute animationen also das wirklich
big brain weder die animation erstellt wie zum beispiel neid vergleichsdrang
narzissmus zynismus und materialismus menschen die egal wofür dankbar sind
neigen deshalb dazu glücklicher und zufriedener zu sein
sie führen glückliche beziehungen und finden schneller freunde sie schlafen
besser sind weniger anfällig für depressionen sucht und burn out und
können obendrein noch besser mit traumatischen ereignissen umgehen in
gewisser weise schützt dankbarkeit nicht davor in eine der psychischen fallen zu
tappen die das moderne leben dir stellt zum beispiel wirkt dankbarkeit messbar
der tendenz entgegen positives zu vergessen ich bin so dankbar dass wir
alle da seid gucken ob ich heute nacht besser schlafen kann nach langer harte
arbeit erreicht kann sich das leer und bedeutungslos anfühlen du findest dich
emotional da wieder wo du angefangen hast und versuchst befriedigung im nächsten
großen ziel zu finden anstatt zu betten bevor oder stell dir vor du bist einsam
und wünscht dir mehr freunde vielleicht gibt es in deinem leben sogar einen oder
mehrere menschen die gerne zeit bloß nicht mit dir verbringen würden aber dir
kommt es vor als wäre das nicht genug du siehst dich als versager bist mit dir
selbst nicht im reinen du schlägst ihre einladung aus und wirst noch einsamer wenn
du allerdings dankbar für die beziehungen bist die du hast sagst du
vielleicht häufiger mal zu oder ergreifst sogar selbst die initiative
je mehr du es riskierst dich zu öffnen ich habe in allem gar nichts zu tun haben
ist die chance beziehungen zu vertiefen und neue leute kennenzulernen im besten
fall wird durch dankbarkeit eine positive rückkopplung ausgelöst positive
gefühle führen zu sozialem verhalten was zu noch weiteren positiven sozialen
erfahrungen führt und wieder positive gefühle auslöst das kommt häufig nach
besonders schweren phasen im leben wie zum beispiel einer chemotherapie vor dann
kann sich das leben plötzlich ganz großartig anfühlen die kleinste sache
alles alle sind sie richtig happy die fähigkeit zu schmecken einfach in der
sonne zu sitzen oder mit einem freund zu plaudern objektiv betrachtet ist ein
leben dasselbe ich muss mal wieder mit dem friseur telefonieren fällt mir
gerade ein oder das diskon das diskon call ein bisschen schlechter aber dein
gehirn vergleicht deine aktuellen erfahrungen mit zeiten in denen das
leben schwieriger war und reagiert mit dankbarkeit kurz gesagt dankbarkeit
richtet deine aufmerksamkeit verstärkt auf die guten dinge in deinem leben die
folge positive gefühle und erfahrung der immer noch bdo ich habe gehört da
spielt jetzt japlow auf der switch gerade wo ich mir auch denke was da los
kann man mehr dankbarkeit empfinden wie du dein gehirn zu ganz einfach mehr
twitch donations nicht mehr primes ab mehr primes ab lagung zur dankbarkeit es
gibt individuelle unterschiede sie kann entweder stärker oder schwächer
ausgeprägt sein das hängt von genen der persönlichkeit im kulturellen umfeld
ab wissenschaftler wollten herausfinden ob es möglich ist an dieser
dankbarkeitsveranlagung und damit auch an der zufriedenheit zu arbeiten
bevor wir hier tiefer einsteigen sollten wir erwähnen dass noch nicht ganz
geklärt ist in welche maße und wie nachhaltig dankbarkeit trainiert werden
kann es gibt leider keine magischen glückspillen
das leben ist kompliziert an manchen tagen hat man das gefühl alles im griff
zu haben und an anderen tagen eben nicht und das ist ok und manchmal wenn du
dich selbst zu sehr unter druck setzt kann das streben nach glück dich auch
unglücklicher machen aber dankbarkeit allein ist kein
heilmittel für depressionen und kann professionelle hilfe nicht ersetzen
sie ist nur ein puzzelteilchen im gesamtbild der mentalen gesundheit die
einfachste dankbarkeitsmethode mit fundierter wissenschaftlicher basis ist
das dankbarkeits tagebuch man muss sich nur was ein bis dreimal pro woche für ein
paar minuten zeit nehmen und fünf bis zehn dinge aufschreiben für die man
dankbar ist vielleicht fühlt sich das komisch an fang deshalb mit etwas
leichtem an okay etwas kleines dankbar sein vielleicht dafür wie gut kaffee
schmeckt oder dafür dass jemand freundlich zu mag kein kaffee
aber hat jemand etwas nettes für dich getan oder fallen dir menschen oder
dinge ein die dir fehlen würden wenn sie plötzlich weg wären und für die du
dankbar sein kannst jeder mensch ist anders finde heraus was sich für dich
gut anfühlt und das war schon ehrlich es klingt beinahe lächerlich eigentlich
dürfte das nicht so einfach sein aber in zahlreichen studien haben probanten
berichtet dass sie sich glücklicher und allgemein zufriedener fühlen nachdem
sie diese übung wir sollten dankbar für snickers sein habe ich jetzt gehört im
letzten paar wochen lang gemacht beitrag studien konnten außerdem noch einige
monate später sondern 385 drei monate excellent subscription ich bin sehr
dankbar für diesen primes ab und der hirn aktivität feststellen dankbarkeitsübungen
können dich also tatsächlich um programmieren dadurch wird deutlich dass
gefühle und stimmungen nicht in stein gemeißelt sind wie du das leben
wahrnimmst beruht am ende nur darauf veränderst du im kern wie du über dich
selbst und das leben denkst veränderst du damit deine gedanken und gefühle
damit auch jetzt wirds aber big brain ja unglaublich dass etwas so simples wie
selbst reflektion die verknüpfungen im gehirn so ändern und damit
unzufriedenheit das stimmt also mal das würde echt vielen leuten gut tun einfach
mal wenn die sich mal kurz gedanken drüber machen würden was sie eigentlich
machen ja das das würde sicherlich einigen helfen vielleicht nicht
unbedingt glücklicher zu werden aber weniger blödsinn zu machen wenn das mal
kein grund für optimismus ist was dann ein mensch zu sein ist schwer aber man
muss es sich nicht schwerer machen als nötig
gehe ein bisschen aufmerksamer durchs leben und du wirst viele dinge bemerken
die es schon jetzt schöner machen das würde den ganzen hate speech leuten auf
twitter mal gut tun oder was heißt hate speech leuten ich verwende das wort ja
einst und gern den ganzen empörungs leuten auf twitter würde das echt mal
gut tun sich ein bisschen umzugucken wie sagt man so schön aus ihrer
filterblase mal rauszugehen da wird mit nächsten monat wieder gesappt
twitter ist voller pp gas ja
was hast du die neue website von von sprich bei den eigentlich aus
riso gesehen nähe
mich interessiert aber auch die webseite von riso nicht sonderlich
was das ist von riso
nindu okay
social media charts und statt das ding und warum warum genau ist es jetzt eine
webseite von riso weil er da oben steht oder was weil er sich selbst feiern will
oder wie oder was oder neue social blade kann man okay ich suche mal nach mir
mal gucken was da passiert oh guck mal mich gibt's
monka es feels bad man
tweets retweets durchschnitt nach fünf tagen pro tweet
137 schlags 12 comments zwei retweets
ein prozent ja interessiert keine sauberste post moment ist es jetzt wird
das ist twitter excellent wo bloß wo bloß hier geht steil berg auf oder auch
nicht gut ich habe jetzt ja nicht geschrieben die letzten tage
aber hier twitter rang moment wenn ich auf twitch
ok das ist jetzt natürlich geht natürlich nix man kann es davon abgesehen
wirklich besser als social plate ist es jetzt an einem dem fehlt vor allem die
langzeit statistik die social plate hat dieser kanal ist nicht aktiv genug um
einen außerhalb kräftigen rang zu erreichen
ja ist so
wirdschrang guck mal hier saman da neue follower was ist das ok das ist so
ein typisches web design ding wo man keine ahnung hat es in irgendwas mit
zuschauer das sind sind das durchschnitts zuschauer
und top zuschauer auf geht's 13 monate excellent
dankeschön um nicht zu sagen das sind top und das sind
durchschnitts zuschauer das sind neue follower ok
typische stream teil das ist interessant zeigt mal her manchmal ja das sind die
sonntags streams und das ist nach der arbeit ja so ein genau genau trifft
trifft sie eigentlich ganz gut typische streamtage also man sieht ich
bin am wochenende motivierter als unter der wochung
aha
na gut jetzt wissen wir bescheid
doch das sagt streams ja näher unter der woche ist ja klar wenn ich arbeiten
gehe dass ich da weniger streben so
deswegen bist du dollars da depressiv ja da musst du einfach nur denken was
wir gerade im video gelernt hast du musst ein dankbarkeits tagebuch führen
und dann bist du dann wieder gut drauf pineapples also sparrer ich habe hunger
leute noch die barbeque pit boys ok pineapples salzer sparrer recipe ok das
gucken wir noch exzellent
brisket hell yeah kona
was sind die barbeque pit boys da kamen heute wir grüllen up some pineapples
salzer sparrer ist das ist real easy to do all right we have a rack of sparrer
erklärt schon mal warnung für veganer ist das jetzt nix da steht was von
fachinformatik da müssen wir auch anschauen das sind glaube ich noch
sachen die vom letzten mal übrig hatte hier fachinformatik war 2012 er will
dann so was gucken geht es geht nur drei minuten das gucken wir schnell noch das
gucken wir schnell noch fachinformatik das ist von 2012 das ist und das ist ein
werbevideo für eine firma ok das ist bestimmt fail das ist bestimmt fail das
ist bestimmt richtig fremd fremdschirm video das muss man zwar kurz gucken
cringe richtig cringe massif cringe wahrscheinlich überleg mal das war 2018
der tipp war da irgendwie 22 jetzt ist er 30
zum fachinformatiker für systemintegration computer und
programme haben mich schon während meiner kindheit interessiert nicht
abgelesen nicht abgelesen wollte felix auch in seinem beruf damit zu tun haben
während seiner ausbildung lernte den umgang mit computer hatten den sound
wieder abgemischt computer und programme haben mich schon während meiner
kindheit interessiert darum wollte felix auch in seinem beruf zu tun haben
während seiner ausbildung hier putti putti ist bestimmt putti ist das putti ich
erkenne es gerade nicht genau und lernte den umgang mit computern und programmen
anders als zu hause wo es sich nur um seinen eigenen rechner kümmern muss
was ist mit der sprecherin los
eigenen rechner kümmern muss was ist das für der sprecherin los
nur um seinen eigenen rechner kümmern muss betreute hier bei eves hunderte von
unterschiedlichen hardware komponenten installiert programme konfiguriert
ganze systeme sind aus xp am start wünsche der evis mitarbeiter überall in
betrieb als systemadministrator kümmere ich mich um das netzwerk volle
motivation computer drucker und bildschirme in allen abteilungen laufen
und auch die rechner gestützten die drucker und bildschirme okrath ich
krieg anfälle sagt marco tiles sein vorgesetzter und ausbilder das ist der
folgesetzten ausbilder kein wunder dass sie alle so motiviert sind in diesem
beruf tätig ist heute profitiert er von dem was er während seiner ausbildung
gelernt hat eine große verantwortung er kann druckerpatrone wechseln
poggers huge diese massive verantwortung für druckerpatronen die
kenne ich wer kennt die nicht ja ich ich spürte jedes mal informatiker pflegen
nicht nur die hard und software von komponenten sondern auch die it systeme
der großen produktionsanlagen und maschinen in der fertigung ok das ist
natürlich schon eine gewisse verantwortung ob der wechsel von
druckerpatronen oder die installation eines neuen bildschirms der
fachinformatiker für systemintegration spielt eine wichtige rolle im
unternehmen installation eines neuen bildschirms weil man da auch so viel für
machen muss konzentration und ausdauer gehören ebenso zu der abwechslungsreichen
aufgabe wie gute grundkenntnisse im umgang mit computern und programmen wenn
du dich hier wieder findest dann ist diese berufsausbildung genau das
richtige das ist wenigstens ein schöner pet schrank so ist das gut
ja das ist wenigstens das ist wenigstens wie in der realität aber das sieht
nirgendwo so ordentlich aus wie in den werbevideos immer so sieht das in der
realität aus genau das richtige für dich und hier nochmal im überblick wurde
euer barnticket in der ausbildung vom arbeitgeber übernommen
nee die berufsausbildung zum fachinformatiker für systemintegration
dauert drei jahre du gehst während dieser zeit nicht nur in den betrieb
sondern auch in die berufsschule wo der block und welcher high IQ mensch hat
dieses ding hier gespielt mit ihm wird das spiel kannst du eigentlich gar nicht
verlieren
der richtung findet du solltest mindestens die mittlere reife erlangt
haben und fit in sachen computer und was macht die fahrradkette da schon im
ersten leerjahr bei 814 euro pro monat moment das ist kein bild der steht
wirklich da fackmann der steht da das ist das ist kein foto der steht
wirklich eine minute da und bewegt sich nicht während dieser zeit nicht nur in
den betrieb sondern auch in die hause schenkt der blockunterricht
der bewegt sich die vergütung den ersten leerjahr bei 814 euro pro monat und steigert sich so
und kommt zu ihm ist das gelaber immer von wegen marktführer das machen sie
alle das machen sie echt alle entwickeln die mitarbeiter die ketten
und antriebssystem ist ständig weiter sieht aus wie beim döner mann sieht
bisschen aus wie beim döner mann die hohe qualität und zuverlässigkeit beginnt
schon in der produktion der einzeln okay das vielleicht nicht außer hat der
gerät des herstellprozesse stück für stück zu einer kompletten kette
zusammengefügt werden dazu werden super moderne maschinen
roboter und kommt super modern bedient von gut ausgebildeten und
zuverlässigen mitarbeiter die oftmals schon bei evis ihre
berufsausbildung gemacht haben wenn du also an den zuverlässigen zukunft
wie jeder robot bietet auch ein döner robot handfeste vorteile findet der
hersteller der gerät wird nie mögen der gerät schläft nie ein
gerät ist immer vor der chef und schneidet das fleisch schweißfrei und
schneidet das dönerfleisch schweißfrei
besser wahrscheinlich gibt es heute diskussionen darüber ob das nicht ein
rassistischer clip war oder so aber da ist keiner typ das ding heißt ja
wirklich der gerät mittlerweile man kann das kaufen unter der gerät okay
kokona video
Wir haben hier ein paar Salsa, ein paar Apelsider, ein paar Riebe, ein paar Tequilade.
Was?
Wir haben hier ein paar Pinapel, hier haben wir ein paar Zwiebeln, ein paar Zwiebeln, ein paar Knöpfe, ein paar rote Zucker
und hier haben wir ein paar Chipotle und Adobo Sauce, um es ein bisschen aufzumachen.
Was? Adobo Sauce? Adobo Sauce? Was für ein Ding?
Es gibt nicht viel Vorbereitung.
Was für eine Sauce?
Wir haben hier ein paar Zwiebeln, ein paar Knöpfe, ein paar rote Zucker und hier haben wir ein paar Chipotle und Adobo Sauce, um es ein bisschen aufzumachen.
Was für ein Ding?
Es gibt nicht viel Vorbereitung, was man mit diesem Rack machen muss. Es ist wie ein ganzes Rack.
Wir werden den Flap noch aufschneiden.
Wir lassen das Fleisch, glaube ich, viel zu lange draußen liegen. Das hat manchmal schon so komische Farbe.
Wir machen das, weil der Flap von seiner Natur anders ausgemacht wird als das Fleisch mit den Bohnen.
Also wir schneiden das auf, damit es noch etwas kocht und wir kochen das Flap separat.
Okay, jetzt haben wir dieses Ende-Pieces aufgeschnitten und es sieht ziemlich cool aus.
Jetzt werden wir das Membran auf dem Backen schnurren.
Es gibt eine Unterschiede zwischen dem Membran und dem Flap.
Einige werden das Membran entfernen, viele Reviles werden es aufhalten.
Wir schnurren es auf, um die Saison zu erlauben.
Bevor wir das Membran aufschneiden, werden wir es mit etwas Mustard schnurren.
Hier haben wir ein paar gelbe Mustard.
Das wird dem Membran aufschneiden.
Also schnurrst du es mit diesem Gemüseblend.
Schmeckt es gut, noch etwas Mustard auf der anderen Seite.
Wer ist das? Ja, ich bin es. Ich gebe es zu. Ich habe das schon ein paar Mal gebated und es ging dann so weit, dass mir einer auf Twitter geschrieben hat, dass jemand auf Twitch mein Logo verwenden würde.
Ich bin es, ich gebe es zu.
Die Anzeige ist raus.
Dass dem noch nicht der Bart abgefackelt ist.
Wo steht er denn da drinne hier?
Oh, yes!
Das macht er gleich.
Also ich bin enttäuscht, dass er das mit einem Löffel mischt.
Normalerweise macht er das doch alles mit seiner Machete.
Etwas Zucker war das gerade.
Das war ja fast eine Messerspitze Zucker.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das das ist, wo das Fleisch eingelegt wird gleich. Würde ich mal vermuten.
Hier können wir uns gleich angucken noch.
Das sieht aber schon gut aus, muss man sagen.
Auf YouTube tut sich da auch gerade nicht viel.
Ich würde es mir jetzt sofort reinhauen, das sieht schon gut aus.
Da fehlt noch ein bisschen Fett, weil ansonsten müssen die Sachen mindestens mal ein halbes Päckchen Butter kriegen.
Schaut euch das an!
Das Fleisch sieht wirklich gut aus.
Das sage ich als Teilzeit Veganer.
Ich bin Veganer solange ich kein Fleisch esse.
Jetzt werden die Subskription verschenkt.
Vorher sah das Fleisch besser aus.
Das sieht ein bisschen verbrannt aus.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach die Soße, die war ich schon relativ dunkel.
Ich würde es mir jetzt auch direkt gönnen.
Was sollte ich jetzt noch angucken?
Einmal sollte ich mir noch angucken, den aktuellen Stand zur Corona App und irgendeinen Spiegel.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das mit dem Spiegel jetzt erstmal an.
Der macht gute Videos, von dem habe ich schon ein paar Sachen eingeschaut.
In letzter Zeit reitet er mir immer ein bisschen zu sehr auf der Welle von irgendwelchen Raspberry Pi Respien Reskins.
Gatschi Hyper fällt mir höchstens ein.
Ich finde das immer geil, wie sie alle HDMI, HDMI aussprechen, das ist ein Wireless HDMI Device.
Aber es ist auch ein Wireless Router mit HDMI Display, die man eh kann, ich mache weiter.
Moment, das heißt einfach nur Mirror, das hat mit Mirror nichts zu tun.
Oder was ist das?
Ach, das ist so eine Art Display Link, also irgendwo anstöpseln, dann über Wireless übertragen und irgendwo Monitor anschließen.
Ich glaube damit fange ich erst gar nicht an, überlegt euch mal, ich würde mal einen 240Hz Bildschirm haben, das wäre ja ziemlich beknackt.
240Hz geht übrigens eh nicht über HDMI.
Ach man überträgt von seinem Handy oder was?
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht man stöpselt das HDMI Kabel an die Ausgabe von der Grafikkarte an, der überträgt das Wireless und woanders dann rein.
Ok, jetzt bin ich verwirrt, jetzt muss ich echt mal weiter gucken.
Es kosten sowas, Amazon, Amazon Hyper Mirror, fast, gibt es anscheinend in Deutschland nicht.
Ach Kickstarter, Moment, ist der Sinn von Amazon Video nicht, dass hier nicht steht die komplette erste Staffel, sondern steht von was die komplette erste Staffel?
Die komplette erste Staffel, ja von was? Hauptsache die komplette erste Staffel.
Ach das ist Kickstarter, nachdem ich, ok die haben für 4000, 4000 ist schon mal viel zu wenig.
Ich, seitdem die mich so gescampt haben mit der Hose, 200€ gescampt haben, bin ich vorsichtig was Kickstarter Projekte angeht, oder 150€ oder was auch immer das war, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Nachdem die mich so gescampt haben mit der Selbstreinigende Hose, also Leute, ich weiß, Selbstreinigende Hose klingt erstmal Lull Max, wie kannst du sowas becken?
Aber das war echt nicht schlecht gemacht und ich hab das denen geklaut mit der Selbstreinigende Hose.
Und ich hab die Selbstreinigende Hose gebackt und die kamen nie an und die sind Scamars.
Kickstarter, Jeans, ja das Kickstarter Projekt ist immer noch da.
Updates, ja, das kam nie an.
Ja, so und die haben damals halt geworben mit, als T-Shirts gab es auch, die haben halt gesagt sie machen eine Hose mit aus so dreckabweisendem Material und T-Shirts.
Und ich fand das klang glaubhaft, weil es gibt ja schon Stoffe und Sachen die das machen und da hab ich mir gedacht, das wäre eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee gewesen mit der Hose.
Und ich hab dann auch hier gleich das fette geplatscht irgendwie mit T-Shirts und ne Hose und es kam nie an.
Man kann pre-ordern.
Guck mal die Domain gibt es noch nicht mal mehr.
Vielleicht kommt da noch was, ja ganz bestimmt kommt da noch was, ganz bestimmt sieht genauso aus als kommt da noch was.
Tja, RIP würde ich sagen.
Nunja, seitdem backe ich ungern Kickstarter Projekte.
Richtig gebadet haben sie mich.
Sie haben mich richtig.
Ja.
60 Gigahertz, das ist ja noch mehr als 5G.
Da ist ja Corona 2.0 vorprogrammiert wenn ich sowas in die Wohnung stelle.
Das geht aber nicht.
MonkaW, MonkaGiga, 60, ganze 60 Gigahertz.
Da hilft gar nichts mehr dagegen.
Außer der Ganzkörper, Alufolienanzug vielleicht.
Okay, Latency Zero ist schon mal prinzipiell gelogen.
Es gibt nichts mit Zero Latency.
Außer Stadia, die haben Negative Latency.
Was sie ja wirklich erzählt haben.
Aber rein physikalisch kann es keine Zero Latency geben.
Unmöglich.
Es ist ja im Prinzip Energy Bait, dass das ganze Lichtgeschwindigkeit heißt.
Eigentlich ist es nicht Lichtgeschwindigkeit, sondern die maximale Geschwindigkeit wie du Informationen austauschen kannst.
Und es ist halt zufälligerweise auch Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Aber es muss kein Licht sein.
Es ist einfach die schnellstmögliche Geschwindigkeit wie du Informationen austauschen kannst.
Und deswegen kann es nie Zero Latency sein.
Ist halt im Vergleich zu den anderen gemeint.
Ja, dann sollte man es zumindest realistisch schreiben und halt nicht Zero.
Sondern kleiner 1ms oder sowas.
Oh, jetzt kommt der Chat.
Das ist nicht zufällig Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Jetzt habe ich was gesagt.
Jetzt geht der Chat ab.
So.
Und warum hat er das überhaupt schon?
Wahrscheinlich weil er Kickstarter gebackt hat.
Ich habe die andere Seite in den Reciever gepluggt und ich brauche den Reciever auch zu poweren.
Was ist das für ein wackeliges Ding?
Sieht nicht so elegant aus daneben dran.
Ich würde das lieber irgendwo dahinter verstecken.
Schau mal, wer YouTuber jemand deine Jeans getestet hat.
Kann ich gleich machen.
Aber ich gehe davon aus nicht, weil die keiner bekommen hat.
Außer die Typen selbst.
Scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich meine auf diese auf diese Entfernung.
Also ich muss sagen Latency sehe ich jetzt da nicht im Video, aber ich meine auf die Entfernung.
Da geht nichts verloren und sonst was.
Schauen wir mal, wo er die App wechselt.
Okay, warte mal.
Egal, gucken wir gleich.
Ach, hier.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, weil da sieht man es auf jeden Fall.
Geht mit Apple Geräten natürlich nicht.
Okay, doch, doch.
Ein bisschen Verzögerung hat das, das sieht man.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Doch, doch, doch.
Guck mal, hier hat man es eben schön gesehen.
Wenn man die App wechselt, guckt.
Also, na wobei, guckt mal.
Also man sieht es hier an den Zahlen.
Also großer Unterschied ist da wirklich nicht.
Guckt mal, nee, nee, nee, das hat nur so gewirkt.
Guck mal.
Also.
Okay, das ist jetzt ein 60 FPS Video.
Keine Ahnung, mit was er das aufgenommen hat.
Aber genau, also erstens, klar, könnte das am Monitor liegen.
Aber selbst wenn, also das ist wirklich.
Natürlich ist es keine Zero Latency.
Klar, habe ich ja gleich keine Zero Latency.
Kann es ja nicht geben.
Das ist zwei Frames oder so hinten dran.
Keine Ahnung, das ist schon, das geht wirklich ziemlich schnell.
Zwei.
Ja.
Sollte das sein?
Paar Millisekunden auf jeden Fall.
Mobile Games, null.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Was siehst du hier?
Jemand, der sagt, du kannst vom Handy zum Fernsehen was ohne Latency übertragen.
Was natürlich offensichtlich nicht geht.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich gering, die Latency.
Das muss man sagen, muss man echt sagen.
Das heißt, damit könnte man Diablo Immortal auf dem PC spielen.
Ja, verstehe.
Und da ist es.
Ich habe persönlich noch nie mit irgendwelchen wireless HDMI gespielt,
also ist es mindblöd, zu sehen, wie gut es hier funktioniert.
Von der Maus, zu meinen Keystrokes auf dem Keyboard,
habe ich keine Latency bemerkt zwischen dem großen Bildschirm und dem Laptop.
Das letzte Gerät, das ich hier wirklich testen wollte, war ein Raspberry Pi,
aber leider hat der neue Raspberry Pi 4 micro HDMI,
also muss ich einen kleinen Adapter benutzen.
Der Use Case, ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht, wenn du von deinem PC was zum Wohnzimmer übertragen willst oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Also wirklich, Anwendungszweck fällt mir jetzt auch kein guter ein.
Na, weniger Kabel gleich einfacher, ne?
Also wenn ich die Möglichkeit, ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Ersatz für Kabel ist.
Dort wo ich ein Kabel nehmen kann, würde ich auch immer ein Kabel nehmen,
weil ein Kabel einfach viel billiger ist und besser funktioniert.
Dann schon der Technikweger halber.
Das ist, wie gesagt, das ist dort wo ich nahe genug dran bin, aber kein Kabel machen kann,
zum Beispiel von meinem PC ins Wohnzimmer oder so.
Basically, das wird mit jedem HDMI genutzt. Und wieder, ich benutze die Maus hier, es gibt keine physischen HDMI Kabel in meinem Monitor, und ich würde nie die Unterschiede hier erzählen können.
Also wollte ich auch den Latentier testen, aber ich habe keine wirklich kostlosen Equipment dafür,
also setzte ich meine Kamera auf, um 240 FPS zu rekordieren, in Slow-Motion, und wir können sehen, wann es auf jedem Bild kommt.
Jetzt gibt es Latency-Tests.
Und wie man hier sehen kann, bei 240 FPS, beobachte ich keine Latentier zwischen dem Laptop und dem wireless Display, den wir hier im Hintergrund haben.
Und es ist eigentlich ein wenig seltsam, denn ein paar Mal, als ich das testete, siehst du es in diesem Video hier, es sieht so aus, als würde es zuerst auf dem wireless Display kommen.
Irgendwas, wo schön kontrastmäßig umgeschaltet wird, wo man auch was sieht.
Ok, was soll der Kram nochmal kosten?
Wow, 120 Dollar, ne.
16 und a half feet, was ist denn das in einer ordentlichen Einheit?
Zu Zentimeter, ok, zu Meter, 5 Meter, 16 and a half feet, das sind typische Kokona-Einheiten, Alter, wieder.
Wie viel kostet ein HDMI-Kabel? 5,50 Euro.
Ok, das ist dann aber kein 5 Meter HDMI-Kabel. 5 Meter HDMI-Kabel ist vielleicht ein bisschen teurer, vielleicht kostet es dann 7,50 Euro oder so.
Aber zumindest eins muss man mal sagen, das Produkt macht, was es soll und das ist das Wichtige, da kann sich jeder selbst überlegen, wir können hier viel drüber philosophieren, ob es einen Anwendungszweck gibt oder sonst was.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung, die versprechen das und sie halten das, da kann man sich jetzt überlegen, ob man das kauft oder nicht.
Wenn man dann denkt, man bräuchte das, warum nicht?
Ich vermeint jetzt da wenig Anwendungszweck daheim, aber solang es drauf steht, was sie können und sie halten es dann auch, ist doch gut.
Zum Beamer ist das tatsächlich wirklich eine gute Idee, falls man da kein Kabel hinlegen will, das ist richtig.
Ok Leute, was sollte ich mir jetzt noch angucken? Irgendwas zur Corona-App sollte ich mir angucken.
Monika Corona. Das ist nämlich relativ neu, das ist hier vorgestern, von vorgestern.
Comments are turned off. Oh, die Verschwörungstheorie ist am Start wieder.
Gibt es einen Chat zum Video? Nein, es gibt keinen Chat.
Ich habe sie nicht installiert. Mein Handy kann das nicht. Smartphone.
Was ist das für ein bescheuerter Vergleich? So eine App in der Richtung gab es doch vorher auch noch nicht.
720p, ist das euer Ernst?
Ja gut, wir sind ja auch in Deutschland im Jahr 2020, da kann man das ja auch nicht erwarten. Das ist ja undenkbar.
Das war auch Zero Latency gerade.
Das ist zu erwarten gewesen.
Moin Twinko.
Wir können froh sein, dass die Ämter das nicht per Fax schicken.
Wahrscheinlich schicken die es per Fax, wenn ich so recht darüber nachdenke.
Wir können froh sein, dass sie die noch anrufen müssen, wenn es schon per Fax ist.
Nutzt du dieses Addon? Ja, aber nicht für Edge. Warum fragst du?
Sie haben gerade gesagt, die App selber ist demnach auch hilfreich, allerdings wissen wir ja nur, wie oft sie heruntergeladen wurde.
Tatsächlich wissen wir gar nicht, wie viele Menschen informiert wurden, dass sie mit einer Risikoperson Kontakt hatten, weil es diese zentralen Daten gar nicht gibt.
Ja, das ist doch sehr schön und sehr gut. Ich denke, genau diese Datensparsamkeit und verteilte Datenhaltung und der Datenschutz ist ja der wichtige Grund, warum immerhin 15,8 Millionen Deutsche bisher diese App heruntergeladen haben.
Wenn man nun ein System hätte, wo all das zentral erfasst ist, denke ich, hätte niemals so viel Vertrauen.
Ja, das stimmt. Man muss ihnen echt mal zugute halten. Sie haben sich diesmal Mühe gegeben. Man kann sich jetzt streiten, warum der Kram so extrem teuer war.
Man kann auch von Telekom und SAP Geschiss halten, was man will. Aber sowas gab es in der Form noch nicht.
Das Ding wurde, nachdem sie vorher schon mit einem App-Versuch komplett baden gegangen sind, mit ihrem Open-Source-GitHub-Ansatz, finde ich echt gut.
Das sollten sie bei allen Sachen so machen. Das würde viel mehr Vertrauen schaffen in die Technik.
Das würde viel mehr Vertrauen in die Technik schaffen.
Und wie gesagt, ich kann jeden verstehen, der da prinzipiell wenig Vertrauen drin hat.
Guckt man sich mal an, von Gesundheitsakte bis Bundestrojaner bis Personalausweis, was es da nicht alles für Sachen gibt, die total in die Hose gegangen sind.
Zumindest aus Datenschutzsicht in die Hose gegangen sind, vielleicht auch aus Funktionalersicht in die Hose gegangen sind.
Kann ich jeden verstehen, der da kein großes Vertrauen drin hat. Aber diesmal haben sie sich echt Mühe gegeben.
Das muss man ihnen mal zugute halten.
Dass hier nicht viele Daten erfasst werden können und nicht viele Statistiken rausgegeben können, ist ein Vorteil dieser App und nicht ein Nachteil.
Gerade das Thema zentrale Datenspeicherung, dezentral, das ist ja auch ein Thema bei der internationalen Vernetzung der vorhandenen Corona-Warn-Apps.
Und darüber habe ich vor wenigen Minuten auch mit Staatsministerin Merkel gesprochen. Hören wir mal rein, was sie dazu gesagt hat.
Da kommt es eben auf die unterschiedlichen Ansätze an.
Wer ist das?
Ganz einfach auch die Vernetzung mit den Ländern, die ebenfalls diesen dezentralen Ansatz gewählt haben.
Schwerer ist es halt bei Nachbarländern wie Frankreich, die sich für den zentralen Ansatz entschieden haben.
Es ist nicht unmöglich, aber immerhin ist es schon möglich, dass in allen EU-Staaten einschließlich Norwegen, Großbritannien und der Schweiz
auch die App aus dem App-Store heruntergeladen werden kann, also auch unsere App.
Ja, heißt die internationale Vernetzung. Die ist zwar ein bisschen schwierig, je nachdem, ob die Daten zentral gespeichert werden oder nicht, aber es ist auch nicht unmöglich, sagt Dorothee Bär.
Zurück zu Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computer Club. Kann man das einigermaßen vereinfacht darstellen, wo da die Probleme liegen, wenn das eben verschiedene...
Ach, das ist die für Digitales. Stimmt, jetzt weiß ich, wer das ist. Ich kann mir das mittlerweile echt nicht mehr merken, wer da was ist.
Ich komm da nicht mehr mit. Die meisten Leute sind auch so extrem profillos irgendwie. Ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht mehr merken, wer da was ist. Ganz schlimm.
Das ist die, die nicht bei der Gamescom, beim deutschen Computerspielepreis in diesem komischen Kleid herumgerannt ist, ne? Die war das doch. Die in diesem komischen pinken Kleid herum gewetzt ist.
Also das Kernproblem liegt eigentlich immer nur darin, ob ein Land dem anderen vertraut, eine korrekte Meldung abzugeben.
Also am meisten vertraue ich den Chinesen über korrekte Meldungen.
Wenn der Deutschland seinen Meldewesen noch nicht ganz im Griff hat, dann können Sie sich vorstellen, wie das nun aussehen würde, wenn Sie diesen Prozess öffnen für eventuell ganz Europa. Das ist etwas, worüber Einigkeit hergestellt werden muss.
Es gibt diesen einen dezentralen Ansatz, der jetzt der de facto Standard ist. Alle Länder, die etwas anderes machen, das Beispiel Frankreich wurde gerade genannt, verabschieden sich von diesem Standard und damit auch von jeglicher Möglichkeit einer internationalen Interoperabilität.
Das hat er aber schön gesagt. Sie müssten nur dann dort eben die französische App benutzen. Potenziell ist es aber möglich mit dem System von Apple und Google, das ja nun bei den meisten Ländern angewendet wird, einfach eine Interoperabilität hinzubekommen, dass ich beispielsweise mit der deutschen App auch eine Meldung in Italien abgeben kann.
Die Basis dafür ist da, nur das Meldewesen im Hintergrund muss jetzt quasi von Apple und Google zusammen mit den Ländern definiert werden, aber der Standard ermöglicht es. Nationale Alleingänge waren noch nie international interoperabel.
Also wie gesagt, was das Melden der richtigen Zahlen angeht, da traue ich am meisten den Chinesen, weil da weißt du auf jeden Fall schon mal von vorne rein, es stimmt nicht. Da kannst du dich nicht auf eine Sache verlassen. Da musst du erst gar nicht anfangen zu rechnen. Du kannst davon ausgehen, das ist eh verkehrt.
Und Google Stichwort Betriebssystem. Im Moment ist diese Corona Warn App ja auch nur auf neuen Geräten wegen den neuen Betriebssystemen möglich. Man arbeitet daran, sagt zumindest die Bundesregierung, das auf mehr Geräte auszuweiten. Wie weit ist man da und wo sind da die Haken?
Also wenn ein Telefon diese App nicht unterstützt, kann das zwei Gründe haben. Das eine ist, dass die Hardware, also tatsächlich die im Gerät verbauten Elemente nicht dazu in der Lage sind. Dann haben wir einfach es wirklich mit einem Gerät zu tun, was technisch nicht diesem modernen Stand entspricht.
Da kann man auch nichts tun. Ein anderes Problem und ich denke das viel größere Problem ist, wenn wir Geräte haben, die zwar technisch in der Lage sind, aber von den Herstellern nicht mehr mit Updates.
Es ging nicht um die App glaube ich, es ging um das Übermitteln von Diagnosen von Ländern zu Ländern. Also wenn jetzt irgendeine italienische App das mitkriegt, sich da einer registriert oder so, dass es dann rüber kommt zu uns irgendwie so.
Sehen werden. Leider ist es ja so, dass wenn Sie jetzt so ein Mobiltelefon bauen, Sie hauptsächlich einfach mal Kosten dafür haben, das zu produzieren und dann einmal bezahlt werden, wenn Sie es verkaufen.
Und viele Hersteller entscheiden eben im weiteren Verlauf in der Pflege dieses Produktes bei dem Bereitstellen von Updates Geld zu sparen. Ist eine Forderung des Chaos Computer Clubs, das dem quasi entgegenzuwirken, indem Updates für einen bestimmten Zeitraum verpflichtend werden.
Oh, das wäre gut. Wird zwar nie passieren, aber das fände ich auch gut.
Das ist Haltbarkeitsdatum für Geräte, denn es ist tatsächlich so, dass Sie heute ein günstiges Mobiltelefon kaufen können, für das Sie im Zweifelsfall nie wieder Updates erhalten und das schon veraltet im Regal liegt, wenn Sie es kaufen.
Und ich denke, das ist nicht haltbar. Erstens, weil wir sehen, dass hier technisch 2 Monate. Dankeschön. Subscription Geräte nicht auf den neuen Stand gebracht werden, dass wiederum auch Leute dazu zwingt, sich wieder neue Geräte zu kaufen.
Das heißt, wir haben nur ein Problem im Konsumenten und Datenschutz, sondern auch ein ökologisches Problem, wenn einwandfreie Geräte im Prinzip obsolet gemacht werden, obwohl sie technisch noch wunderbar funktionieren würden.
Das wollen die Hersteller im Endeffekt. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich mir, also ich habe mir ein ASUS Tablet gekauft, ein ASUS Android Tablet mal und die haben nicht einmal ein ordentliches Update geliefert, nicht einmal.
Es ist voll für den Arsch gewesen. So, und was habe ich jetzt? Also ich habe das für meine Mutter gekauft, das ASUS Tablet. Was habe ich danach gemacht? Ein iPad gekauft. Bäm, geht. Geht, kriegt Updates und sonst was.
Und einfach zum Benutzen ist das top.
Also viele Nutzer berichten ja auch von Fehlermeldungen, die sie nicht richtig einschätzen können, zum Beispiel die Meldung, die App sei in der Region, obwohl man sich vielleicht gar nicht von zu Hause weg bewegt hat, auf einmal nicht mehr verfügbar. Was ist das?
Ja, diese Fehlermeldung tritt auf Apple Telefonen auf und kommt tatsächlich nicht von der App selber, sondern vom Apple Betriebssystem. Also diese App nutzt eine Funktionalität, die in das Apple iOS Betriebssystem eingebaut wurde.
Diese Fehlermeldung kommt tatsächlich dort her. Sie hat ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass das Telefon natürlich weiß, dass in unterschiedlichen Ländern potentiell unterschiedliche Apps laufen und versucht, dem irgendwie ein bisschen Rechnung zu tragen.
Ich habe gesehen, dass es heute Morgen ein neues Update für das Apple iOS Betriebssystem gibt und ich hoffe, dass diese Fehlermeldung damit dann auch Geschichte sein wird.
Das ist sehr ärgerlich, stört aber die App nicht in ihrer Funktionalität. Es stört aber natürlich die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer, die von dieser Fehlermeldung teilweise mehrmals am Tag behelligt werden.
Ich hoffe, dass das nun ein Ende hat. Gleichzeitig ist zu sagen, diese App und diese Funktionalität wurden in relativ kurzer Zeit programmiert und es ist bei jeder App vollkommen normal und auch bei jeder Betriebssystem Erneuerung völlig normal, dass es auch Fehler gibt.
Nein. Habt ihr schon jemals einen Bug gesehen bei irgendwas, was ich on stream programmiert habe?
Ist ausgeschlossen. Kann nicht sein. Komplett bugfrei. Immer.
Und auch völlig normal, dass die zügig behoben werden müssen. Heute ist es ein Monat her und ich denke...
Nicht einmal, genau.
Ich hoffe, dass mit diesen Updates jetzt die Fehlermeldung Geschichte sein wird.
Vielen Dank, Herr Neumann. Also wir fassen noch einmal zusammen. Die Corona-Warn-App, die ist jetzt seit einem Monat am Start. Das ist dann jetzt auch wirklich mal an der Zeit, dass einige kleine Bugs, die dann noch von einigen Nutzern festgestellt werden, behoben sind.
Insgesamt, das sagt zumindest auch der Chaos Computer Club, ist man aber mit dem dezentralen Ansatz, der ja auch die Daten schützen soll, der Nutzer zufrieden.
So, wie alt ist das Video? Das ist neu, das ist drei Tage alt. Warum das so eine schlechte Bewertung hat, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil nicht darauf eingegangen wird, dass Wuhan 5G und Bill Gates und ach, was auch immer. Keine Ahnung.
Ich war beim Friseur. Also beim Haareschneiden Friseur, nicht bei dem Friseur. Und die Mädels da, die müssen ja auch Masken aufhaben.
Und die, die mir die Haare geschnitten hat, hat die Maske über den Mund, aber nicht über der Nase gehabt.
Ich hab auch gedacht, okay, irgendwie, entweder hat sie keinen Bock drauf, oder sie hat die Funktionsweise nicht genau davor, nie verstanden.
Äh, weil es eben, eben die Diskussion gab, Apple ist teurer, also gerade bei Tablets, gerade bei Tablets ist es nicht so.
Wenn ihr euch ein ordentliches Android Tablet kaufen wollt, ist das genauso teuer wie ein iPad.
Es ist nicht sogar ein bisschen teurer, wenn ihr die eins kauft, wo du auch auf jeden Fall ein paar Updates kriegst.
Hat sie eine Brille? Nö. Hat sie nicht. Keine Brille. Keine Brille und nix.
Sie sieht ausgesprochen hübsch aus, muss man sagen, ja. Aber das entbindet trotzdem keinen davon, sich die Maske aufzusetzen.
Da muss man sich halt auch mal verunschtalten, ja. Das erkennt man halt nicht, dass man so hübsch ausschaut.
Genauso wie die eine auf Facebook, die diesen Werbepost für ihre Facemask gemacht hat, die Löcher drinnen hatte, wo sie geschrieben haben,
das würde die feminine Seite besonders hervorheben und da hat es jetzt halt so eine Maske mit Löchern drin.
Das ist komplett fein. Also manchmal glaube ich, die Leute sind einfach zu... zu low-brain.
Lost. Genau. Komplett lost. So.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass die meisten, also ja, die meisten Leute sind dumm, aber dafür sind sie nicht zu dumm.
Also den Zusammenhang zwischen Maske über Mund und Nase und das, wenn es nicht über Nase ist, den Zusammenhang können die meisten Leute schon erfassen.
Also da brauchst du ja einen EQ von unter 70 wahrscheinlich, dass du das nicht kapierst. Also das ist schon echt low.
Aber die sind entweder hirnlos, die denken einfach nicht dran oder sie machen das absichtlich.
Genau, das interessiert ihr nicht mehr. Da hast du bestimmt einige.
Ja, ich habe ja auch die gleichen Playlists vom letzten Mal wieder angemacht. So Leute, ich habe übertrieben Hunger.
Ich muss jetzt was futtern. Mal gucken, ob ich vielleicht später nochmal ankommen.
Müssen wir mal schauen. Ich schaue mal gerade, ob man irgendjemanden haben, den wir hosten können. Und zwar, wen können wir denn hosten?
Irgendwas Kleineres, dem ich auch folge, der es verdient hat und wo es auch was bringt, weil irgendwelche 5000 sonst was Zuschauer-Channels muss ich nicht hosten. Die haben schon genug.
Nö, keiner da.
Welche Event-Streams stehen bald an? Also es gab ja letztens einen über den Playstation 5 Controller und der war Hyper Resident Sleeper. Langweilig.
Xbox kommt jetzt. Wann ist denn das? 6 PM. Gibt es das vielleicht auch in normalen Zeiten? 18 Uhr.
Okay. 18 Uhr. 23. Events. Wo habe ich es denn? Ja. Ah, da haben wir es doch schon. Da haben wir es doch sogar schon eingetragen.
Genau, Luke. Wir haben jetzt gelernt, immer schön dankbar sein. Dann lebt man glücklicher. War nicht E3? Nee, E3 ist dieses Jahr ausgefallen.
Die haben nur ein paar Pressekonferenzen gemacht, zu der gleichen Zeit.
Excellent Musik. Was? Hier sind alle Events aufgelistet.
Ey, das war so mega langweilig. Das war so extrem langweilig. Ja, das war es.
Passende Outro-Musik würde ich sagen.
So, Chet. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Ich gehe mal was essen. Bis dann. Macht's gut. CU.
Musik